People like it's not natural.
I say what the fuck is natural?
Okay.
We're full Morgan Murphy.
We are alive.
How are Ya?
Fuck is going on.
Is that a space balls tee shirt you
wearing?
Uh,
no.
It's um,
the no,
no limit.
No limit soldier tee shirt.
Oh Shit.
Like master P,
whatever happened to that dude.
He's got a weed store.
I think murder.
Oozie murder.
Isn't he in jail for murder?
How odd.
There's a lot of,
uh,
yeah.
A lot of people are in jail for murder
right now.
It's very big.
Yeah.
You don't have to do a your entire life
though.
I used to think that every time you
murdered someone,
that's it.
You go to jail for life and people get
out of jail for murder.
Yeah.
That seems a little fucked up.
It doesn't seem a little far down.
A little fucked up to have to,
uh,
I always imagine like,
I wonder if they go back to their
hometown,
like where they murdered somebody.
Like that's always the fucked up part.
To me.
It's like going back to the place where
you're the town murderer.
Yeah.
It's fucked up.
The in moment of just a freak out.
You could change your whole life.
You'll have just fucked and the other
end of the person's life just isn't
around anymore.
Just stops done.
Yeah,
the finality of it all.
Okay.
It's crazy.
It's a little uncomfortable.
I don't want you a snapping.
I feel like you get snap.
I'm not as an opera Aria.
I'm super calm.
Really?
Yeah,
pretty much.
Especially in like physical altercation
time stuff.
I'm very aware of consequences.
What if you were on like your 10th lift
of something,
like an aggressive workout and you're in
the middle.
You have all the,
you know,
all your energy is just moving forward
and you're lifting your kettle thing and
it's number 10 and someone just comes in
and like tells you your mom's stupid.
I would be even less likely to do
anything because I'm already exerted.
I get it.
I think of the body.
This is a shitty theory,
no biology attached to it at all.
But I think the body is like a battery
and I think almost like maybe a battery
of a battery was a bucket and this thing
can overflow.
And I think that's what you get when you
get road rage.
That's what you get.
You get people at snap for no reason.
I think they're already coming at you at
like eight.
They're not like,
hi,
I'm Morgan.
Hi,
I'm Joe.
And we meet each other at zero.
Right.
I think some people are meeting,
yeah,
they're already at six and they're just
ready to snap.
Right.
It has nothing to do with you.
They should have let a little out of the
starbucks,
a little out in the car,
a little out,
you know,
at home with the kids and then a,
and then they wouldn't murder anybody at
the end of it.
And people will say,
well,
you know,
you just need to work on your breathing
and well you need to work on your,
your being present and you need to be
mindful.
And I think all those things are
correct.
But I really think that your body has a
certain amount of requirements and I
think depending upon your stress level,
those physical requirements might be
higher,
right?
Like if you have a job and your job is
like some high accountant at some big
firm and you're crunching numbers and
it's fucking stressful as shit,
I feel like your body thinks that there
is some physical danger involved.
And I think your body amps up for that.
And then when the physical danger
doesn't come,
your body's just fucking primed and
ready to go.
But there's nothing,
there's no action,
there's no fucking action.
This fucking duck got me off.
And then they start doing that shit.
Fuck,
fuck you that get in their car and
they're just,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Because in your car you're ramped up
even more because in your car you're
aware that you have to be,
you have to be really acutely aware of
everything that's around you.
You have to make sure that no one's
making any mistakes because you're all
going 65 miles an hour and a little eric
and happened really quickly.
So you're on edge already.
When you're in your car,
even if you're calm,
you're,
you're in your car,
your sensors are tuned in.
If you're fucking paying attention,
if you're a healthy human being,
you're looking left and looking in the
mirror.
You look in,
right?
You're checking and make sure that
you're okay.
You making sure that no one's doing
anything stupid,
and then you compound that with the
stress of your daily life with no
physical release.
Right.
We don't have animals.
Casey now send anymore invading tribes.
That would be fun though to have a
buffalo chase you all day and then you
would have,
you would release the proper amount of
energy given the threat.
It would be a realistic,
we'd have a more realistic population.
Yeah,
I like it.
That would be one thing.
We don't like that though.
We just,
whenever anything like gets like too
close,
we just kill them off.
Just kill them off.
Fuck that.
Fuck.
I've buffalo's everywhere.
Kill him.
Just fucking kill him.
Stop.
There's consequences.
I don't know.
I gotta I gotta go to work.
Kill it,
kill it.
That's a bigger problem.
Went round in America.
Do you know that a,
they reintroduced wolves into America in
the 1990s.
Now there's this giant debate whether or
not wolves should be here.
Oh,
really?
Where'd they do that?
Yellowstone.
Yeah.
I think they're bad ass,
but you've got to keep an eye on the
fuckers.
Yeah.
I get a lot of coyotes in my,
uh,
in my neighborhood.
A lot of,
kind of a lot of coyote neighbors,
super common all the time.
I had a biologist on who tracks coyotes.
It's what he does.
Oh,
he does track Iot is around Los Angeles
and he's like,
dude,
they're fucking everywhere.
Yeah.
So they were living in middle of
downtown La and the most crowded area,
they had a debt.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I call my neighbor is my,
not when there's a coyote,
if I see a coyote going up their
driveway,
go,
hey,
as a kid.
And I had called them.
If somebody knocks on the door and
asking for money for some organization
and everyone gives each other and alert,
oh,
that wasn't the coyotes or a proper
environmental la or whatever.
Yeah.
Those people just knocking on your door.
Ooh,
that's a bad feeling.
I gave him money for bees one time they
got me,
it got me all nervous about bees and
saving the bees and I was like,
Oh shit.
I gotta say I really went from like,
I'm,
I'm having coffee and a cigarette to
like,
oh,
I got to save the bees now it's my
responsibility to solely do it
does not also depend on like where your
head's right?
Like if
your head is it a really good place and
someone knocks on the door and you don't
know who they are,
it's cool.
You're like,
hi.
You know,
like hi,
we're here to save chimpanzees.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
Like what do you,
what do you guys do?
And then you start talking to him.
Well,
if they can like within a minute,
make you understand something you didn't
understand before,
you're like,
oh shit,
now I got to pay attention.
Right.
They sucked me in because I wasn't aware
of our bee situation.
Oh,
so they immediately hit you with some
facts and facts.
I was like,
oh boy.
Now,
how are they going to save these bees?
I don't know.
Let me get with my,
with my $40.
I think just here,
take this paper when just go handle it.
Yeah,
go handle it.
Yeah.
If the bees die,
we're dead.
We're all dead apparently except in
China.
They figured out a way to pollinate
things with uh,
just a brush.
There was an issue where they were
really low on bees and they tried
reintroducing bees and it didn't take.
So um,
last ditch effort was they took people
with a paintbrush and they dusted the
pollen on all these different plants.
Like one at a time they pollen,
they literally pollinated all these
plants and apparently worked way better
because bees are sort of nonspecific.
Like bees are just going over there and
they're doing their thing and they just
get shit on their body and it transfers
over to the plants.
It's really kind of fascinating how it
works,
but these people did it very
specifically with a paintbrush.
It was really interesting to do a,
b,
it's job.
The person who can find the video of it.
It's kind of fucking weird because like
you could make the argument like we
don't really need to beach once you want
honey,
honey is not even really good for you.
How about that?
That was going through my head and then
they explained to me why we need bees,
which I forgot but
it was enough.
I had a guy come to me at whole foods.
This is my most intrusive,
I think the most intrusive is when
you're in the parking lot at whole foods
cause that's when they usually get ya.
When you're walking out they try to get
you right as you're walking around it's
fucking hot outside and you have like
ice cream and shit and you're like hey
dude,
you also like 17 you know $17 ice
creams.
They know you have a,
they know you have a few bucks cause
right now because of Amazon we want to
do that anymore.
Amazon just bought whole foods so we'll
just just be able to one click your
shit.
But I'm this guy,
he hits me up,
stops me in the middle,
like stops me,
stands in front of my car,
puts his finger up.
Do you have one minute for gay rights?
Like what's that one minute is not gonna
help shit man.
Like what are you talking about?
I vote like what do you,
what do you want me to do?
Want me to donate?
Is it,
what's this one minute.
What do you gonna tell me?
What are you going to tell me?
No,
can you tell me Shit?
I go,
no,
I do not.
I vote for gay rights though.
Take it easy man.
Like you fucking,
that's an annoying activist.
What a whole fish.
Is this at the hills right here.
Right up the street.
Fab is trying to figure out where that
whole foods alliance.
I don't know what the deal is like where
they're allowed to have people.
This was a couple of years ago.
Honestly,
I just still complain about it because
I'm kind of a whiny bitch.
But um,
I don't know what the deal is.
Like are you allowed to just set up shop
anywhere and put like one of those
picnic stands and you know they
have like one of those little plastic
tables.
They sat down and they show you a
picture of a baby with a bloated belly
and to show you,
yeah,
you hope it's girl scout cookies and it
turns out to be just a horror show.
Yeah.
Pending apocalypse.
I almost think like when I see someone
like some kids selling lemonade or
something like that,
I'm like,
oh,
this is like you guys are doing like a
throwback thing.
I almost feel like,
oh,
you guys are doing like an old time.
You're making your own butter.
Look at your kids.
You're,
I think this is not sustainable.
This is not a real thing anybody does
anymore.
You get a lemonade stand.
Okay.
Did you,
did you,
how did you make,
did you get a horse and ride your horse
over here with this lemonade stand?
There's all these parents now helping
lemony.
You can't do it alone.
You can't do anything alone anymore.
Oh wise.
It's always parents there and soy.
Those helicopter parents don't touch
somebody's belly.
Don't put junk in your mouth.
I would sell a,
when I was a kid,
I would like take my books and stuff and
sell them in my front yard.
Like I would just put them out.
I thought it was fun to have my own
garage sale,
but I didn't see my mom for like,
you know,
seven hours of the day and I come back
and sign.
She goes,
do you do,
I made $4 like she didn't know how I
made $4 just selling all my shit in the
front yard and she didn't see me or ask
me anything.
Different Times,
different times,
parents were just,
they just let you out,
they let you out.
But I was,
this was like in the 80s,
which was priming.
That was like a,
that was kidnapping was,
was hot.
You know,
your mom had faith and you're avoidant
skills maybe.
Yeah.
You think about like how people used to
raise people.
Like everybody I talk to,
they just let their kids out.
Like when you were,
you know,
my age,
I'm 49.
When I was like,
uh,
seven 42 years ago.
They just let,
yeah,
the House I got,
I used to get kicked out of the house,
but I was given a time.
I had to be back.
It was a very like,
broken system of like get out,
but come back by five and don't walk
under the overpass tunnel.
Like I was given the rules.
That's where the trolls given rules.
Like what year did they stop doing that?
Like just letting kids out.
Like when did that stop?
Because everyone my age says the same
thing.
They said when we were kids.
Did you get just let out of your house,
Jamie?
Yeah.
Jamie's young.
How old are you,
Jamie?
34.
He's younger.
A lot of 22 year old.
Like they're fucking dude old ship
broke.
Somebody called me a geriatric on
twitter the other day.
I was like,
how dare you,
how dare you.
But if you,
uh,
if you're Jamie's age,
you've got let out.
We would ride our bikes miles away from
our house.
Yeah,
but you lived in the woods?
No,
it down by Columbus.
That's the woodsman you might as well,
and I would walk down,
I would walk down Ventura Boulevard.
I'm just like a practically a
thoroughfare when you're a kid.
Oh God.
I would walk past like they had these
motels where the door opened,
uh,
open directly to the sidewalk.
You know those motels?
Yeah,
those are the best.
That was where I was sure I was going to
get kidnapped and her arm was going to
come out and grab me in.
So I would walk and then I'd hop past
the doors,
the motel doors,
motels,
pay my beeper bell.
Those are weird places.
Yeah.
Pay Your beeper to beeper at a pager.
It was like a 12 and that was like what?
I saved up all my money for it because
everyone had one.
No one wanted me messages.
Yeah,
I had,
I had all that shit and I would die.
Walked down to J and j beepers in studio
city and paying cash.
It's like a 12 year old,
my beeper bill.
And then I would jj king of beepers.
Is that it?
I think it's the same.
A Cha,
same la like this.
There was a lot of j and J.
I feel like people uh,
stole the still the name.
I forgot about that dude.
The king of beepers at Turquoise.
Clear.
Get a clear beeper.
Those rare,
those are slick.
That's some star wars shit.
I'd be,
I paid myself so that I had messages in
there so people looked at it.
I had no friends.
The king of beepers is,
this is Jj bupers Las Vegas.
Oh,
well he was in la too.
I don't know if the same guy or maybe
like,
it's one of those things where it's like
Kleenex,
like all the other guys,
like that's the right name for it.
Just start calling ourselves Kleenex,
you know,
like it became,
do you think that it was all jay?
Jay is pink dots and there's also pink
elephant.
Like I think people just kind of a
little pink pink's,
they probably started it.
The hot dog place doesn't,
just the biggest weird fucking event in
La is a God damn line of people to buy
hot dogs.
Nobody from ally.
Well,
here's the thing,
put hot dogs on a regular fucking menu.
Good luck.
Better not by a lot of hot dogs.
Like if you have a rescue regular
restaurant and you have hot dogs as one
of the offerings,
how often do people,
is it even won a 10 hot dog?
If it's like one of two options,
like at Burbank airport you can get,
you can get a hot dog or like a packet
pre packaged salad and occasionally I'm
like,
you know,
I want something fresh like a hot dog or
a Turkey sandwich that's sort of moist
and some weird way.
The bread's kind of what like fuck is
this right?
Wet bread in lieu of a Mayo or
condiments and of course it's sporting
events.
The UFC,
there was a hot dog,
hot dog at a sporting.
It's good.
It's good food for a sporting event for,
you know,
it's recreational food,
right?
Picnics and barbecues.
Sure.
Always hot dogs,
right?
It's a good move for a barbecue.
It's simple.
You can't really fuck it up.
If it looks brown on the outside,
it's done right.
You could eat it raw.
It doesn't need to be cooked.
You can eat it right out of the package.
So that's,
it's a good move for that.
But somehow another pink's is convinced.
People just by cooking outside,
they just have a big open area where the
cooking right in front of you and
everyone was like,
Oh,
I wore lows and there's a fucking line.
I think the line is why people go,
I think people,
people have to go for a line and the
line is outside.
You can see the line.
It's not like Astro Burger,
like 2:00 AM where you can't see the
line.
The line is exciting.
It's what draws tourists.
I think that's Jamie Masada strategy.
See the line.
He's always got that crazy line outside
the laugh factory
and he makes a comics wait in line too.
Really?
Do you don't know the hill a little
while but no,
no,
no.
I don't know that
they're open.
Mike deals kind of nuts.
Like you have to get there at like nine
in the morning and you wait outside and
if you leave you lose your spot.
So you have to like have some sort of a
friendship with the other.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I would say the comedy store had it
situated.
I mean the open mic when,
when I was started with,
it was like 15 years ago,
I would,
uh,
Bobby Lee was the host of the open mic
and he knew I had to,
I was in college,
I was in school and I was in class so I
couldn't go all day and wait.
So he would slide my name into the open
mic and I didn't get to come after
class.
That's sweet.
That was real cute.
Real cute.
The,
the open mics were always weird.
Right.
There are always weird.
And in La they're extra weird cause
there's so much.
I feel like if you can make it to be a
professional comedian and you started
out in La,
you're a rare person.
Well it's all,
it's,
it's 50,
50 comedians and then just like,
you know,
mentally ill,
transient also comedians,
but we're also committed.
Yeah.
It's all,
you just,
you just wait and you go,
all right,
it's going to be my friend.
And then it's going to be a,
that guy who has all of his belongings
with him and then it's going to be my
other friend and then it's going to be
that crazy lady and then will be me.
Can you just wait,
wait and wait and wait and you just
wonder what kind of fucking diseases are
just festering on that microphone and
also just what's the point of this?
What am I doing right,
especially in the beginning.
Yeah.
To have vision and hope.
Like what was your initial goal when he
first started doing stand up?
Um,
the really simply like a,
I think it was,
I knew I liked writing a lot.
Like even before I started doing standup
and I think stand up,
uh,
I've tried to figure it out.
The,
the,
the easiest way to explain it I'd think
is that I just wanted to see if what I
was writing was funny.
And so that's sort of why even when I
started at me,
I'm still dead pan obviously,
but when I started I was so dry because
I was essentially just reading out loud.
These thoughts I have with no real
performance background and I wasn't,
you know,
necessarily a performer at heart.
Right.
So it's just like reading one liners and
going,
is this funny?
Is this funny?
Get a laugh.
Keep it.
Don't get a laugh,
throw it away.
But if you,
if you throw it away like you never know
sometimes is it,
is it me?
Is it the way I'm delivering it?
Is this joke?
Is it a good idea?
But it's kind of,
it's done wrong.
Yeah.
And then at that time too,
you don't have the,
uh,
the,
the ability to perform at a hundred
different places so you're not going,
okay.
It works in the alternative room.
It doesn't work at the club or it's just
like,
oh,
well it didn't work at the laundry mat,
but it worked at the coffee house.
I wonder what that means about this
joke.
Right?
It's like jokes,
it'll work at the UCB,
but they bomb on the store.
Yeah.
Like why,
what's going on?
Like why did that get an applause break
at the UCB?
They just fuck it.
Stared
at me in the main room
following rick and Grub,
they just stared at you.
Sometimes at UCB is hot.
I mean that's just anywhere that comes
out of your mouth.
It's weird.
And then sometimes,
nope,
it's a weird place.
It's weird.
They don't pay too.
That's also super weird.
Yeah.
I think if I was,
I,
I'd be a little,
uh,
less,
I might even that upset,
not upset about it,
but I feel like I'd be less upset if I
was like involved in the school and
realize that it's,
oh,
it's so kids can take classes at like a
decent rate,
I think.
Isn't that what it's for?
So that kids can take really cheap
classes there.
Isn't that what it sustains?
Like the,
the shows,
what kind of classes do they have?
Like comedy classes,
Improv and shit.
Oh,
can you teach?
Well maybe you can teach improv.
Huh?
Do you believe you can teach stand up?
Uh,
I believe you can teach somebody.
I think you can help somebody,
uh,
encourage them to get on stage.
But I don't think you can teach the the
ability to be funny.
No,
I don't know what,
you know,
it stand up in what capacity?
Like I guess you could teach somebody
to,
you can mold their thoughts into jokes
and help them and shove them on stage,
but I don't know who,
what kind of comedian that makes.
Yeah,
I feel like boy,
it's one of those things where I've
learned a lot about it.
So I always wonder like maybe you can
teach something.
Cause I've definitely learned some shit.
Well,
yeah mean people,
you know,
I think there are,
if you find out your favorite comedian,
you know,
sits down and writes an hour a day at a
starbucks or whatever,
you go,
oh maybe I'll try that.
Like little tricks and things like that.
But I don't know.
I don't know anyone who's a,
you know,
who,
who I deeply,
deeply admire who had credit all their
success to their comedy classes?
No.
Well there's not enough classes.
There'd be like a real poor focus group.
But I know Ari did an interesting thing
while back where he used to go to a town
like when he was doing stand up and like
he was headlining for the weekend.
He would go to a town and you would do
like a free seminar for the local
comics.
Tell them like desire,
you get a manager,
stop asking people to take you with them
on the road.
When you're two months into comedy,
stop asking you know,
managers to handle you.
Like you just got to get good first and
then give them all this advice about
like getting an agent and you know,
yeah.
I went,
uh,
I went to Penn U Penn recently and I was
talking to uh,
some students and I don't,
I don't flake fancy myself,
like an instructor of any kind,
but they were asking me,
you know,
about comedy writing,
this is specifically in stuff.
And the advice I gave was very,
uh,
practical and had nothing to do with the
craft,
which was just like,
don't be annoying in the room.
Uh,
don't,
you know,
like in a TV,
like it did it like in the writing for
like a TV show and like jokes don't
work,
don't go,
that didn't work.
That's not your job to say that.
Like that kind of shit of just like how
to get through the first year without
annoying everybody dies.
Think that's not taught right.
No one ever does that.
Shut up.
Like shut up is a great rule.
You can make big mistakes.
Yeah.
And you can be a person that nobody
wants to work with you then it doesn't
matter how talented you are.
Yeah.
That's a whole brighters oftentimes a
very awkward,
right.
They can be,
it depends.
Like the rooms are very split into when
I got into like Sitcom stuff,
like it's just very split into um,
very just internal,
uh,
kind of what you would typically think
of as like a writer.
And then there's a couple of comedians
sprinkled in there who kind of bounce
more jokes around.
It's just a win and people who are just
good at structure.
Hmm.
Yeah.
That's an interesting thing that people
that are good at structure cause
sometimes they try to be funny sometimes
but it's not,
you know,
once you fight,
the thing I like about like those rooms,
obviously it's so much fun to be in a
room with Comedians,
but once you realize how that person can
do anything,
I can't and I can do a thing,
they can't,
you start to realize like,
oh we could go into a room and get a lot
of work done together.
That is the thing,
right?
It's like lining up the pieces and no
matter how much you want a square and a
circle the line up,
they just,
they just don't seem to.
And when you have like a writer's room
or anything like that,
I think a big part of it depends on just
the fortunate chemistry of all the
people coming to there.
Yeah.
And that first day where you show up if
it's not your room and you haven't hired
anybody and you don't know who's there
is a terrifying because you show up and
you know,
within five minutes if this is going to
be a fun x number of months or if you're
just going to be trudging through,
what's the biggest shit show you ever
had to work on?
Um,
I,
I've had really like tremendously good
luck as far as like just working with
friends and stuff on so many things.
But I worked on a award show once and
the boss basically didn't let me write
jokes.
Like didn't they needed to hire a woman?
And I guess I was recommended and a,
and he just,
he,
I was like,
I'll take a stab at these jokes.
And he was like,
no,
no.
Just write the,
the banter where it says like coming up
next is this person.
And I was like,
like anyone can do that.
Literally wouldn't allow me to write
jokes.
So he got hired as a joke writer.
And then once you got there,
he just wanted you to write narrative.
Just banter.
It just like,
you know,
like is,
from the hangover and please welcome
him.
Deserves specific and that,
is that what they call it?
They call it banter.
Like when you're riding things?
Yeah.
Well,
no,
I mean like that in my 20s or run on a
lot of award shows.
So there's like the jokes that
monologue,
all that stuff.
And then there's just the going out to
commercial and come back and all that
stuff has to be written.
And sometimes they try to make it funny
and sometimes they don't.
But you can take it up,
break it up in terms of like,
this is the,
these are the jokes,
this is the banter,
this is the narrative.
This is the structure.
Yeah.
The last,
I mean,
I was just writing on the NBA awards
that are going to be on,
and I'm getting a 26 of the of the
month.
Uh,
drake is hosting on TNT and it's just
like,
it's,
you know,
I mean,
I brought it on ever written on the sbs
before is this,
is like
that.
But for just MBA and we've been doing,
you know,
it's a combination of like,
I read a lot of monologue jokes.
There's other guys who are better at
sketches,
like light film sketches,
tape pieces,
there's live comedy stuff on stage.
Then there's,
you know,
like I said,
like the kind of a little more boring,
like this next person a is the,
you know,
two time mvp.
So why this guy hire you?
You really think he hard to just cause
you needed a woman.
Yeah.
Wow.
Yeah,
I know he did.
That's so crazy.
Yeah,
I knew it all.
I knew it all when it was happening.
Yeah.
Ooh,
that was willing to let you try.
No,
that's fine.
That's foolish.
Yeah,
it was,
it was bizarre.
And it was,
it was the only case of,
uh,
like,
you know,
sexism that I think I've been confronted
with,
which is,
I mean,
I guess lucky in 15 years,
I don't feel like I've,
you know,
I've had that and I was on,
I mean for years and years and years,
I'd never worked with another woman.
I was the only girl and,
and everyone treated me great.
So it's a tougher road for comics to be
a woman.
Yeah.
I can't,
I mean,
it's so funny now.
I,
it's so hard to the landscape right now.
I think so many women are being given
chances that didn't even exist 10 years
ago.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's interesting to,
uh,
to see,
but I never had,
I don't know,
I never had like,
uh,
those kind of sexist roadblocks,
if that makes sense.
Well,
I think that like starting and
developing as a female,
it's more difficult just from my
personal observations because men a lot
of times don't want to laugh at women.
They definitely don't want to laugh at
women telling them things about like
politics or world events.
Right.
Like a woman that seems informed,
like for whatever reason they'll
tolerate a guys,
especially if it's a guy like Ron White,
right?
Distinguished looking gentleman with
silver hair.
Absolutely.
One of my favorite voice.
If Ron's up there and he tells people
something about some sort of a fact,
like people will sit back and listen.
Oh,
I didn't know that.
If a woman gets onstage and tells a man
or a group of men about a fact that it's
very rare that they're going to go,
wow,
I didn't know that.
That's amazing that what the fuck does
this bitch now?
Right?
So there's that.
There's that,
that's a,
that's a roadblock.
And then the other roadblock is,
um,
well there's a lot like you can do sex
jokes now.
Obviously Sarah Silverman kind of broke
a lot of that downward.
So much of her was just straight dirty
and hilarious.
And then Amy Schumer of course,
and a lot of the people,
but it's still,
when you're developing,
when you're coming,
let me starting out.
It's like more,
it seems like it's more of a difficult
world to navigate then a guy telling sex
jokes.
Yeah,
it's,
it's a difficult world.
And it's also like socially,
it's,
uh,
I think the precarious,
it's interesting because what I realized
when I was,
you know,
1920 was,
you like that,
that aspect
of people like dating in the scene and
all that kind of stuff.
All that happened too.
And I've found that if a woman who was
new ish around,
like my level of time was dating
somebody else,
they were automatically looked at as
like a comedy groupie.
And that was the thing that didn't apply
to men.
That was the one part where I was like,
I don't,
I don't quite get that guy.
Not totally true.
Because I've seen some guys that are
dating like famous women and they're
sort of like underlying sort of men
shored up comics and everybody treats
them like they're a comedy group.
I found her,
saw that a lot when I was,
when I was younger that the opposite
where it just,
I didn't see men getting tagged with
that.
Uh,
but that label and that,
but that I was so scared and paranoid of
being,
I was,
I was so scared of being considered
anything other than a comedian that I
like for years and years.
Didn't date anybody,
uh,
in,
in comedy at all because I was worried
that if I showed up to a show with a guy
who,
you know,
potentially it was more successful than
me,
then the first thought would be she's
the girl who's with that guy,
not she's the girl who's going up next,
not just dod,
but she's with that God because of this.
She thinks always going to be the path
when in fact there's a lot of people who
have legitimate relationships that where
that's not the path that just you need
to treat.
You're attracted to somebody and you
know,
eventually I,
you know,
I made my way through a few people.
It's just another prejudiced.
It's just one of those things.
Another prejudice that you have to sort
of overcome.
Like you,
if you'll actually liked someone and
they happen to be comic though,
what the fuck do you do?
Like you say,
if you like someone and they happen to
be some big time comedian,
like what are you supposed to do?
Not like them now.
And they're like,
you look at it,
not like them.
That's stupid too.
It is stupid.
But I was,
I was a,
I was terrified of,
uh,
I don't know.
I just,
I think it was very eager to,
um,
to improve.
Impress.
I don't know.
I was very eager to prove myself.
And maybe that is partly,
you know,
being a woman.
I,
as much as I didn't find it harder,
I did find myself wanting to prove any
stereotype that anyone might have about
me wrong.
I don't,
I don't feel as much of that as like a
mission anymore.
I just who I am.
But I think you have a lot wrapped into
your head when you're young end.
Especially when you're just,
you really aren't stable as far as like
financial.
You're not,
you're really not a real professional
anymore or yet.
Yeah.
And then once you become one lins,
once you're established in the
community,
knew after a while it's like,
what am I,
what am I wasting my time and I'm
thinking about this shit for.
So I think it's harder for chicks to
develop,
but I think once they become good and
once they get out there,
there's a lower bar.
I don't know,
I think there's,
I think the bar is the same.
I think the bar is the same height,
uh,
for most good people.
And then there's like another bar that's
higher for the great,
you know what I mean?
I just think like,
I don't think the bar is lower for
women.
I think it's lower for people who are
not as famous,
not as successful,
not as established,
not as good,
but I don't know if that,
like,
I just,
I don't know.
I think it's,
I think the bar is the same for men and
women.
I just think it's a,
there's a code.
There's a few different bars.
What I mean by that is that I think that
it's,
it's easier to get a lot of attention,
uh,
early on if you're good and you're a
woman because there's not that many of
them.
Yeah,
sure.
I think it's,
yeah,
I mean I would,
I would apply that to any person whose
something that is rare in comedy,
like a specific little finality.
But then you have to prove yourself.
You always have to prove yourself.
I mean,
and then I dunno,
I,
I see comedy too in these,
there's so many different factions.
Mean there's people who are so great at
standup and then as a writer and
somebody who tries to make like,
you know,
projects and wrap them around people.
I also see so many people who I though
that's not my favorite stand up.
That's not a great standup in my
opinion.
But that's somebody I would love to
write for that.
Somebody I'd love to put in a show like,
so I see all these like columns of
comedians and I judged people
accordingly.
And I think there are legitimately
comedians who are not like,
they're never going to be,
you know,
prior a Carlin or Louie or anybody like
that.
But you go,
oh,
I would,
I would put them in a hundred tv shows
as a funny person.
Oh yeah.
So I don't know,
I tend to like look at it from that
perspective too,
where I see,
I see the potential almost in spite of
the materials sometimes.
Well,
there's definitely that,
you know,
and there's also like the difference
between those guys and the guys that are
in like funny movies like Adam Sandler
type movies.
So sure.
It's got a gang of those guys that are
always in those movies and they might
not necessarily be the best standups are
the kind of guys you want to see.
But they're great in those movies.
Yeah.
I mean,
and then it,
but it's,
it's,
I mean,
who's,
I don't know in that,
in that group,
like my favorite standup is probably
norm who,
I mean I went to go see the,
they did a netflix movie and then I like
a tour with all the actor,
you know,
the comedians from it and it couldn't
have been a bit different group of
Comedians and you go,
okay,
well norms.
My favorite stand up there and I go is
norm,
you know,
going to be the lead of like,
uh,
you know,
Adam Sandler movie?
Probably not,
but he's the person I would go to.
Any theater,
any room,
any,
you know,
a coffee house,
whatever it is to go see.
Yeah.
It's,
it's one of those things I guess
when you,
you,
you look at,
you look at things in categories like
you know that Kevin Hart does his own
standup,
but you also know that he does movies
where the people,
right,
the lines and I'm sure you helps make
them funnier and all that stuff.
And he's reading a script essentially.
Yeah.
And then there's people that go on stage
doing stand up and you,
you know,
like you could be like,
I guess you could be like a really
amazing performer and just have some
wizards behind the scenes that right for
you and you could make a fucking
incredible standup act.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
that stuff's so interesting.
Yeah.
I have a very specific,
like,
you know,
if I was the boil down the standup that
I,
you know,
the,
the standup comedy that I love and
respect the most,
it has nothing to do with TV and has
nothing to do with
it has,
it's just comedians,
right.
Who they are on stage.
And that's,
you know,
that's how I judge who I love and don't
love,
uh,
as a comedian.
But there's
so many other factors in show business
that you have to sort of take into
consideration.
I mean,
we like a lot of people who are very
famous,
who might not be
the very best,
but we know them the most.
Right.
Well,
what I was going to say is that when
you're,
when you're doing standup though,
for whatever weird reason,
the people that we all love the most are
almost always people that like right for
themselves.
Yeah.
And it's very difficult to get,
like say you're not going to get bill
burr to write for some ca creation,
like say FCA,
how's,
I'm fucking comic.
He's got perfect cheek bones and he's
got a great way of delivering jokes,
but he's,
he's not capable of writing.
They're the right level of material.
Like one of the problems is a guy like
Bert rights for his own mind,
right.
Rights for his own thing.
Like I'm sure he could write for that
guy,
but he's not going to get the best
stuff.
Right.
It's just not going to be the same.
I,
yeah,
I mean I,
I'm,
I,
I've never,
I think we've all taken like a tag or a
segway or something where a friend goes,
dude,
add this to your joke and you feel like
you already wrote it.
I mean I look at three year fight with
somebody in my twenties of her who wrote
a joke and I thought he did and he said
I did in the car and I refuse to do it
until he convinced me that I came up
with it.
Cause I was so paranoid about doing a
joke that I thought somebody else wrote.
But yeah,
I mean that's the thing too is that
there's some material that's so funny.
Fucking great.
And I watch it and I go,
I don't know how to make that a show.
And maybe it doesn't even,
maybe it's not even supposed to be a
show,
but like someone like Louie,
I think,
I mean a repeat it and he says he's my
favorite.
But like
I could have never written Louis show.
Louis had to write Louis show.
Right.
But there's a lot of comedians where I
watched some and I go,
oh I know,
I know what I know what they're showing
you how to figure that out though.
I'll absolutely like you Louie.
He did that show on Hbo.
Yeah,
I had a conversation with them after it
was canceled.
At the Improv and the first thing he
said is,
I just,
I should have written it myself.
I would have fired everybody.
Yeah.
And just written it.
He goes,
it's like the problem,
a big part of it is just you're dealing
with all these people's visions and
you're trying to get yours through and
it's like yours might not necessarily be
better,
but the problem is it's yours.
And in order for,
for the thing to be the thing that
you're happy with,
like just like your act,
it kind of has to come through.
You like Save,
you were going to do a Netflix special
and they said,
look Morgan,
we think you're hilarious.
We love to do a Netflix special with
you.
But what we'd like to do is assign a
team of executive producers and writers
and with,
they're going to do is they're going to
change your look.
Okay.
We're going to go with a goth
theme.
We're going to put black lipstick on you
and,
and we're gonna just w yeah.
They're going to come up with some
fucking nutty thing that they decided to
do and then change the way you deliver
material.
It would be like,
what,
what are we doing here?
Right.
I think that's kind of how Louis felt
when he was doing a show.
It's like all this,
there's all these other voices,
maybe not as retarded as a golf vampire
black lipstick I get.
So like I get so passionate about about
making things like other people's
things.
Like I just get excited.
I see somebody on stage.
I'm like,
I want to,
you know,
like my job right now is just to develop
tv stuff and does it ever fucking
happen?
Number two stand up to still stan hope.
Yeah,
we're going on tour for two weeks on a
Tuesday.
Um,
and then he continues and I have to come
back for some writing shit and,
but I get,
you know,
as passionate as I get about standup,
I get so fucking into the idea of like
seeing somebody go up,
seen the show that they could have and
also wanting them to love it because I'm
like,
no,
I get you.
I'm not going to write anything that you
would say that you wouldn't do.
Like you want to be as the writer.
On the other side of that,
as the person who is sometimes hired to
take a comedian and like get a show out
of them.
Like I liked to hope and think that I
have a perspective that someone who's
not in standup maybe wouldn't have.
Because I'm like,
I,
I've watched this person so long,
I know their voice,
I know what they're commenting on,
I know the way they're commenting on it.
And I hope that if I write a script for
them and they read it,
they're not going to go,
fuck,
this isn't me.
You know,
I'm so,
I mean I'd,
maybe it goes back to like wanting to
and press or wanting,
you know,
to be seen as legitimate,
but I would never,
I would never hand somebody something if
I thought that it was remotely
embarrassing her against their,
you know,
there's a lot of people will.
Right.
But I mean,
I,
I find it to be an interesting sort of
responsibility and,
and,
and like when you're hired to sort of
develop shows is all this shit they
bring you like,
Hey,
there's an article about this.
Do you want to write a show about this
thing?
And I'm like,
every time I say no,
I wanna I wanna write something for a
comedian.
I,
that's,
so that's like your specialty is what
you want to do.
It's what I wanna do.
I mean seeing,
watching someone from comedians
perspective and going,
Oh,
I could do something with that.
Yeah.
And also like I,
Tim Allen,
that I think that there's so many
people,
you see where you go,
I,
they're not as successful as I think
they should be.
And I think I know how to,
how to fix it.
Fix it to your cleaner.
I'm a clean,
you're a cleaner,
right?
You're the person they bring in.
Ah,
that would be the like,
uh,
the,
you know,
the wolf and a pulp fiction.
Yeah.
You have a harvey cartel character pulls
up in a silver NSX and it takes notes.
Sound like,
hey,
any show where it's like a woman's job
is to clean and then coming in cleaner
you like waiters on,
cause you're always fucking stepping
through.
It actually is like mildly embarrassing
to passionately talk about,
uh,
television and show business.
Like it's,
it's,
there's a little part of it that's like,
Oh,
who cares and why does it matter?
But I don't know.
Listen,
I think anything that's interesting to
you should talk about and people say,
well,
you know,
you're going to bore the fuck out of
people.
You are,
you're going to bore the fuck out of
some people,
but you're going to bore the fuck out of
some people with things that I think are
really interesting.
Whatever physics,
nature things that I think are
fascinating.
Some people are gonna think of stupid
just so you have to,
whatever's interesting standups.
Interesting to us.
It's always going to be,
I hadn't,
I'm into anything that is passionately
and intricately discussed.
You know,
I'm interesting shit.
If it's a,
if I'm a,
as the Sam,
I knew him in an enthusiast enthusiast.
I don't know a lot about one thing,
but I love anybody who does.
Yeah.
I'm with you.
I'm 100% with you.
I liked a lot of cool shit.
There's a lot of interesting shit out
there.
There's so much anybody tells me they're
bored.
I'm like,
listen,
you're not bored.
You're inactive.
You just need to find things that you
enjoy doing and then you will never be
bored.
Just keep doing things you like doing.
It's just hard for people to get that
initial momentum.
Just get moving.
Go forward.
Sure.
It's not boring.
This is not boring.
This is crazy.
You are finite life form on a planet.
It's whole thing's crazy.
It's chaos.
I got scared as fuck the other day.
I saw another article,
and yellowstone,
they're saying it's a 10% chance and
inside this hundred years,
who's going to be a super volcano
eruption?
So inside this from 2000 to three,
you know,
2000 to 2,100,
there's a 10% chance that everything
dies.
The whole planet,
everything on this continent dead,
everything else,
all over the rest of the world is going
to be fucked because there's not gonna
be any son.
I got a book,
some Glasgow dates.
That's the move.
So I think South Africa,
yeah,
it might be.
The New Zealand is a,
is a big one for people escaping the APP
apocalypse.
New Zealand's awesome.
I know a lot of Americans,
a lot of,
uh,
you know,
tech people,
big,
big money buying land in New Zealand and
it's beautiful.
I want to yellowstone supervolcano hit
by a swarm of more than 230 earthquakes
in one week.
What in the fuck people,
how many wake up calls do we need?
See,
we're not going to be even paying
attention to this until the lava is
shooting up into the atmosphere.
Do you know?
They didn't even know that it was a
super volcano until like 50 years ago or
something.
They didn't even know this is,
I like this pocket that you just,
it's just a talk about shit and learn
how you'll die.
Not always.
Sometimes weren't learn about beautiful
things.
Scared now though,
like vibram five fingers,
toes,
shoes and boxing matches.
This is those things like that that are
why I'm like,
why would I quit smoking when I can just
wait it out.
See what you're,
but don't you feel like shit when you
smoke a lot?
Uh,
when I smoke a lot.
How often do you smoke?
Do you smoke a day?
Half a pack.
It's not that bad.
I mean,
right now,
but it gets crazy when,
when I,
when I have deadlines and stuff and I'm
writing,
I tied it into writing,
which is a bad,
how does that work?
Does the eye,
I've smoked Tony Hinchcliffe cigarettes.
Yeah.
I smoked a cigarette with him before a
show wants and I was like,
dude just gives you like a buzz.
Yeah.
And he goes,
yeah,
I can't imagine writing or doing standup
without it.
No,
really.
My Dad's interesting.
Yeah.
I've gone over to hinge.
Could wait,
wait,
he's a go hang out with it.
Cause a,
you know,
similar,
similar lifestyle I guess.
Is it easy to like a,
have a cigarette with him and talk about
comedy?
Both.
Okay.
So what you're saying
presumed,
presumed to be gay.
Not,
that's hilarious.
Um,
but what is the thing about writing and
cigarettes?
Like what does it do and what does it do
that like a cigar doesn't do,
I don't know.
It's uh,
it,
there's,
it ties into,
uh,
it's a,
it feels good and then there's momentum
sort of involved.
And then you get into a place where
you're like,
Oh shit,
I'm,
you know,
in one cigarette I wrote all those
pages.
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I really don't know chemically how the
addiction part of it works,
but I know I,
uh,
I'm a victim of it.
Yeah.
We'll,
the addiction part is,
um,
pretty clearly documented in that movie.
Um,
with what the fuck's his name inside
man.
Guy from gladiator,
Russell cider.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
the insider inside.
Yeah.
Inside man's different movie.
Right?
Yeah.
What the fuck's his name?
Let's try and do grow by surprise or
Crowe.
Gladiator.
Dude,
that guy,
he was young.
I didn't see it.
I think,
I don't want to know.
I think I liked Christina.
She's a scientist in the movie.
Yeah.
And they're trying to kill him cause
he's releasing all the information.
Apparently that's like hundreds and
hundreds of different chemicals.
The FDA's approved cigarette companies
to add cigarettes just to get a more
addictive.
Yeah.
It's interesting too,
cause I'll have like a,
I'll put out a cigarette and a glass of
water or something and uh,
and then I get nervous if the water
would tobacco and it touches my skin.
Like I get paranoid,
but I'm like,
I'll,
I'll literally inhale every chemical
deep into my lungs,
into my veins,
but I get nervous about like touching
Nah,
tobacco.
He water.
That's so weird,
man.
What is it about like maybe like
bringing it into your lungs?
You're not saying it so it doesn't freak
you out as much.
There's a,
I never thought I could be in as much a
sort of denial about something as I am
about smoking.
But I enjoy it a lot right now.
And I also started late.
I started late.
How old were you?
I smoked real,
real casually through my twenties and
then I started a job at like 29 30.
I'm 35 and that's when I really started.
That's when I started smoking during the
day.
Nene and smoking.
Oh,
before that you would smoke at night.
Only smoke it like a party with a drink
or something.
And when did you notice that had crossed
over into a part of you?
Um,
I think just a couple of years into a,
I was writing on not two broke girls and
I was smoking at every possible break
and it just started to pick up where any
opportunity to go outside and smoke.
I,
I took and then I couldn't stop.
Yeah.
I hate to be that proselytizing health
guy.
You ever tried dip?
That'd be a good,
uh,
no.
I,
I'm gonna I want to try some stuff.
I just,
you know,
I want to try it.
Like I can't even,
I'm not even allowed to like,
you know,
I'm on a lot of like antidepressants and
stuff,
so they don't want me to take the,
uh,
the medication that helps you stop or
any of the gums and it's all supposed to
fuck up your brain chemicals.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Have Weird.
You're on a lot of antidepressants.
I mean,
I'm on a,
I'm on,
uh,
talk about happy hour cocktail while I'm
smoking weed.
I'm gonna,
uh,
nice,
you know,
cocktail of,
of stuff stuff.
What is the stuff?
Um,
right now,
what am I like a sir?
It's like kind of the main,
you know,
I'm,
things are sort of dabbled in there.
It just,
it depends on the timing you get on
different things,
different times of year
in Somerville Inland,
almost 20 years of being on stuff.
I've,
uh,
I've been switched around a few times to
20 years.
She started in high school.
Yeah.
Henry Rollins got put on a real life in
high school.
I'm sure.
100%.
Like,
not,
yeah,
I mean it was where the,
uh,
the term,
I mean I,
I've had a couple of instances of I
don't want to do this anymore.
I don't want to be on it anymore.
I tried to go off and realize I needed
it,
but you know,
high school was the biggest turnaround.
John 80,
the stress of,
I don't know,
I was a,
I was just a mess and uh,
and then some doctor,
you know,
after a year of being a mass was like
try this and so you were suicidal?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
16 you know,
moved around every year.
It was just a,
you know,
a chaotic that
always fucks people up,
but it always creates interesting
people.
Everybody I know.
That's interesting.
Had some sort of a weird childhood where
they moved around a lot.
By the way.
How annoying is it when someone starts
making a point while they're holding a
joint?
A very important point I'm going to
make,
right?
Yeah.
You also know you're not getting that
joint till the end of the point.
And you have to sit there like fixated
like a dog waiting for a treat,
you know?
But yeah,
I moved,
uh,
I lived with my mom until I was like pho
at 1415.
And then I lived with her sister and I
lived with my dad's sister and I live
with some family friends.
I live with my dad for the first time
when I was like 17,
and I just bounced around La,
Connecticut,
Oregon to use us and a,
and I was,
uh,
just brutally depressed and couldn't,
you know,
I mean obviously there were big
environmental factors,
but at the end of the day,
it just,
it was a more than more than therapy
institute.
Your life was
the plot of the movie.
Twilight never saw it.
Should I see it?
Oh,
for sure.
It's classic.
It is a classic now,
right?
Twilight.
Twilight is a movie that was fucking
massive.
Yeah.
Massive.
And now never discussed.
Never discussed,
not discussed at all.
Like people will talk about star wars to
the end of fucking time.
No one's going to talk about twilight
and a couple of years.
No,
they're just not going to,
or there might be like a 20 year reunion
where all the girls who watch it when
they were 13 go see it again.
Yes,
sure.
But there's going to be a bunch of
people like what the fuck was wrong with
it?
What did we do?
Like what happened as a culture?
What happened as a society?
Well,
we decided that all of a sudden vampires
allowed to go out in the day Werewolf's
of abs.
They could change to a wolf,
whatever the fuck they want.
Like what?
What are you doing?
Wasn't there a lot of vampire shows for
a minute too or yeah,
they're all glad to,
yes.
Everybody went crazy on vampires.
Zam zombies are dead to me.
They're dead boring as fuck.
You try to put out a Zombie movie now.
Nobody gives a shit.
I go,
I get it.
It's going to walk slow and you're going
to get away.
And the people that you really like real
live z boring
like here's the a,
here's what the movie's about.
It's,
they're not zombies.
Are you excited now?
Yes.
Oh,
good.
Yes.
In the whole [inaudible] the movie is,
it's about a Gar and his daughter
becomes a Zombie.
He loves his daughter,
but chooses homepage.
Got It.
There's an Arnold Schwarzenegger movie
like that?
No,
that was always a sad,
it's the saddest part of a walking dead
was when you realize like someone had
like their daughter chained up in a room
because he couldn't bring himself to,
you know,
put a spike through her head.
So they just,
he just kept the Zombie daughter.
Oof.
You know what's fucked up?
That is not entirely impossible.
It's entirely impossible that the bodies
would stay active like long after
they're deteriorating minutes.
She has been going on for years.
These zombies have been alive,
eating nothing for your no digestive
track.
Somehow or another flush stays on their
bones.
Their tissue allows the body to keep
moving.
It's ridiculous,
right?
That they even have anything in their
brain at all that allows them to keep
moving.
But as far as like a disease that
changes the host and makes the whole
supervise,
it's fucking rabies.
Rabies on steroids.
Very possible,
very possible with you all the horrible
things that happened double like all
these different animals in terms of like
parasites getting their system and
forced them to commit suicide and all
that.
You ever seen that aquatic worms one,
it gets it to a grasshopper and then
talk the grasshopper and a jumping into
water and drowning so it could pop out
of its body.
No develops in its body and then like
the alien and the movie alien,
[inaudible] side of the chest literally
rips out of the things body in the water
and then that's how it gets born,
like it gets into the grasshoppers body
and then rewires the grasshoppers brain
when it's time to hatch and convinces
this fuck to jump into the water.
It's the beauty of childbirth.
It's walnut.
You can live,
you can make a bunch of kids.
We have the Duggar's,
well they have like 20 they're not a
single time they'd been drowned,
but if you stop and think about that
being real,
like how weird is it?
The idea of a person becoming a Zombie,
that's something that's not weird at
all.
Are you becoming some super hyper
aggressive thing like a rabid dog that's
not,
we're not looking at this thing come out
of its body.
I don't like it grabs a out of money.
This is,
this is horrific.
It's shooting and the grasshoppers just
gutted and this thing now is swimming
around in the water and there's a ton of
those.
There's a ton of those.
There's something,
one that happens with 'em
aunts and a wasp.
I forget who takes over who,
but there's,
there's got find that one is an aunts,
I think I want to say that the ants take
over the wasp.
Like a lot of them,
y'all,
something happens with a rewire.
It sprays out of Bot fly.
Oh Wolf or him coming out of rabbit.
Oh Jesus.
That was one of the things in that
movie.
Rats.
Did you ever see that movie we were at?
No,
but it looks like flex documentary.
That thing's huge.
Holy Shit.
That's a wolf form.
It looks like a grocer,
like groundhog day thing.
It looks like the first two digits of
your pinky.
Like it's literally that big.
Right?
It came out of a rabbit.
Um,
but uh,
they uh,
that documentary on Netflix rats was all
about how many rats live in like New
York City and urban areas.
Fucking insane documentary.
I can't recommend it enough.
Like I always kind of knew there was a
lot of rats in New York.
Yeah,
it was here the numbers.
But when you see like guys who are
exterminators are people who work with
rats and they go down in the basement,
it's like there is an underbelly to New
York City and a lot of other cities to
Los Angeles for sure where swarms of
rodents are underneath the city swarms
more than there are people probably that
there's no way for them to count.
They do rough estimates.
They really have no idea.
But you see them everywhere.
They've got cameras that are dipped into
probes and they're smart as shit.
But one of them are this Bot fly and
they pulled this bot fly out of its
body.
It's like if you were carrying a
football and one of your tits,
like literally just the pull this thing
out of its body.
It pulled it out of its neck.
Actually.
It's fucking huge.
It's like as big as its neck almost.
I'm not into,
I'm not,
I'm a,
I'm a real a morel pussy when it comes
to bugs and you should be,
they're terrifying.
They're the worst.
I saw a spider a in Arizona last week.
That was,
I mean it was half my fist.
I was like,
I had a exos shell,
like a skit.
Like it didn't look like it was wearing
armor.
Horrific.
What kind was it?
I don't know.
Dead stupid now.
Just swamp.
Kill it.
If you strongly you can't hang.
I couldn't,
I,
well I'm not going to go to bed with a
without their living with a bug
somewhere in house.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a lot of weird shit and Doug's
area and die
over a busy area.
He's just right next to Mexico.
It's like knocking on Mexico's door.
You can run to Mexico.
Like literally trying to,
those spiders had papers,
Bill.
Oh Bill.
Well just let the Mexicans then just
everybody relax.
That's a terrifying when you'd leave his
area and they uh,
you got to pull over and stop and they
ask you if you're a Mac,
if you're an American citizen.
Yeah.
That's weird.
And then you go,
yeah,
I know a dude who has a ranch and it's
in south Texas and they find dead people
on the ranch sometimes where people
tried to cross paths,
they just die of dehydration.
Yeah.
Out in the desert.
Fuck,
that's a hard way to go.
And then these ranchers just find them,
you know,
scary shit and you don't know who did
it.
I mean the other thing is like if for
him and his,
his place like,
uh,
you don't know if this guy's going to be
a nice guy just trying to come over here
and get a job or if this guy's a drug
runner and a murderer,
like you really don't know.
You just know there's a person in your
ranch that's not supposed to be there
and they might not even speak English
and like,
Woo.
Trying to think of something I would die
to get to.
It seems to me to be here.
A lot of people get mad at me when I say
this,
but I'm gonna say it anyway.
I think it's something that's going to
go away.
The idea of countries and you can only
go one place,
like if you're born on this patch of
dirt,
you can only stay in this patch of dirt.
It's an impediment to progress and it's
an impediment to quality.
And I think that we've got,
there's gonna come a day where people
are just gonna be able to travel
anywhere they want and we're not going
to look at it like cities and we're not
going to look at it like in terms of
like,
you know,
you're lucky if you live in Boston,
you can move to Cleveland.
If you live in Cleveland,
you can move to Miami,
but you can move,
you can move wherever you want,
but as soon as you have a country you
can't move.
You have to paper.
You got to get it approved.
Well,
what kind of job do you have,
Morgan?
Are you,
uh,
you,
you have a specific skill that would
benefit America and extent of the rest
of our sloppy fucks and half of them
don't you jack.
Shit,
are you better than the average person
washable that jam.
We only want to like quality people in.
That's it.
I would never be able to prove myself in
that moment as being worthy of getting
into any country.
They have a scale.
It's like exceptional skill,
person of exceptional skill.
It just seems,
it seems fucked.
Like I dunno,
just,
it seems barbaric.
Like it really does.
And I know people are Google man,
just fucking go to understand American
sovereignty.
It's very important that we keep the
rest of the world's fucked up.
We've managed to figure out,
we got lucky,
we got lucky and we got shit out on the
right patch of dirt.
Yeah,
sure.
And we got,
uh,
we have,
resources that a lot of other countries
don't have.
And I don't know.
I,
I try,
I love to travel internationally.
I love,
you know,
putting myself in places that,
uh,
are,
you know,
the,
that don't have what we have.
If that makes sense.
Like I am just for perspective.
I enjoy the present and enjoy making a
vacation.
Sort of a combination of a of,
of pleasure and perspective,
uh,
as much as I can.
And going places that you know,
make you realize what you have at home.
Do you think that it holds back both
sides?
Do you think it holds back Mexico that
the United States is so difficult to get
into and then it's always like just a
spare of certain people trying to get
into Mexico,
trying to get an American can't.
What I was going to get at is that I
think that it's kind of similar in some
way and I might be off what's similar in
some way to make drugs illegal
[inaudible] that like you make drugs
illegal,
then you create this artificial there
this demand is increased demand and then
it's outlawed.
So only people that are willing to break
the law sell it.
And so you that you had this criminal
criminal enterprise attached to
something that should be
perfectly legal.
I'm right coming.
You're already breaking the law by,
by bike,
by coming here.
Right.
So are you a person is going to break
the law,
right?
You're going to be a person who takes
that shot,
I think,
and also profit off of it by brand,
like one of those carriers,
right?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I grew up in La and I think I had a,
uh,
I didn't realize that it was illegal,
you know,
as a kid,
you don't know laws or rules or
anything.
So I just assumed that Mexico and
California,
because I would,
you know,
most almost the kids who went to school
with were Mexican.
Like I just assumed that it was like a
place where people live in both places
and you go back and forth a lot and you
know,
the Mexican culture was so sort of the,
the whole,
my whole backdrop of my childhood was
painted with that.
So I just kind of assume that you went
where you wanted to.
Yeah.
And like that La was mostly Mexican and
that was fine.
Yeah.
It should be fine.
Right.
And people will want to look at her,
come over here and take our jobs.
We're going to come over and Bruno
Erchonia working or is it all gonna even
out?
Like maybe it just evens out.
Isn't that possible?
Like,
yeah.
I also,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's beyond cliched to say,
but are they,
are people taking jobs that Americans
are dying to do now?
Yeah.
Well see,
so if they come over here and they can
just come over here,
then you have to pay them the same rate.
It's like you have to pay them the same
rate that everybody gets paid.
Sure.
There's wage limits
as a minimum wage.
If you have them illegal,
you could pay them whenever the fuck you
want.
And they do.
That's like the big housekeeper dilemma.
How can that,
how the fuck fucker housekeepers asking
for a raise?
I don't ask her for a raise.
You can't say shit.
Every time the word housekeeper comes
out of my mouth,
I like,
uh,
I get a little,
I get a little red,
little embarrassed because I have a
housekeeper now.
I never had,
you know,
I mean,
I just feel bad.
It doesn't make me feel bad.
I,
I absolutely,
I couldn't love her more and she's very
much become kind of a,
a pseudo mother figure of mine in La.
I don't have family here really.
And,
but I also feel like that makes me sound
like a pretentious white person who's
taking care of a person of color.
It like,
it really,
uh,
it's not comp,
it's not comfortable subject for me to
talk about.
And yet I couldn't be more like
earnestly grateful and thankful and,
uh,
I couldn't adore her more and,
and really,
she helps me function in life and yet
the varies the subject is,
you know,
I mean,
I didn't grow up with that kind of
stuff,
so it's,
it's embarrassing.
Well,
as long as you pair well and you're
nicer,
it's just a job,
you know,
as long as she enjoys doing the job and
she gets paid well,
it's just a job.
There's nothing wrong with being a
garbage man.
Yeah.
Something wrong with any job.
I mean,
I,
you know,
she's known me through apartments and,
so it's,
it's,
it's interesting when someone just a
part of your life and,
um,
and seems to care about you more than
you even think they should,
if that makes,
like she,
well,
you're her boss.
I'm her boss,
but she's the only person in my home.
And you know,
I,
I trust her,
but she also seems to care about me in
this way.
She wants me to have a kid.
Like,
she's like,
it's all these things that you're,
you know,
I don't really talk to my mom's like,
I have this,
this housekeeper who was like,
you should have a baby and then I'll
take care of it.
She has like a plan for my whole life.
Well,
I don't do it yet.
And tour,
it sounds like you've got some sort of a
partner,
a life partner.
I didn't have a life partner.
Shivaas Teresa life partner.
I Dunno.
It's,
it's,
uh,
it's always a touchy subject because
there's historically been people that
have come from other places and they've
immigrated into places and then,
you know,
they create neighborhoods.
And they,
there are certain class of people
initially and then they move through
society and I mean my people have
experienced at the Italians,
like when my grandfather came over here,
there was all these like negative
stereotypes for Italians and there's all
these slurs like these to call them my
Guinea wop and all these different,
they were like hurtful.
Like today if you call someone a Guinea
knowing like I would say I'm a Guinea,
like nobody gives a shit.
Call Sebastian again.
He'd be like,
Yep,
like it doesn't bother anybody.
You know?
It's like it became,
they became a class of people that
normalized.
They just,
they fit if they fit in with like
regular white people,
like Italians were not considered white
people the same way.
A lot of people from the Middle East
that have like the same skin tone are
consider white people by some people
today,
you know?
But if they,
if there was more,
if it became just say normal part like
Irish people [inaudible] Irishman,
glamorous woman.
Yeah.
I enter swimming.
If they could become white people.
If they just figured out a way to get
white to get wider,
we should just just gotta be away.
Just keeping doors moving to Oregon.
Have to wilder evolve the lack of Sun.
They will evolve into being white
people.
Yeah,
I dunno.
I just think you know,
anytime you restrict things that should
be normal,
like moving to a better spot so you
can't move to a better spot.
Like,
oh I can't,
I can't,
what if I buy a house in that spot?
Nope.
Can't move to that.
Well,
I mean it's,
it's sort of arbitrary and like how do
you,
there's some,
I'm very fascinated by like migration in
general of like towns.
Where are you're encouraged to stay?
Like that is always very interesting to
me.
Like you don't leave,
don't leave,
don't leave.
Like what if you were told you can't
stay,
you have to leave and you have to go
populate this other area.
Like what's the different,
you know,
it just,
we're,
we're choosing where people
can live and we don't know what would be
the best place for them.
We don't know if the best place for them
is right next door to you,
even if you don't want it.
I was watching a guy,
Ooh,
on TV.
They were doing this interview with him.
He was a coffee farmer in Hawaii and
the,
he started out as a 15 year old in
America.
So He's been in America from the time he
was 15 he was in his forties now he has
a family.
He's been in America for us more than I
think.
I think they were saying like 30 years.
Okay,
so this guy,
why family worked his way up from being
a worker at this coffee farm to owning
the fucking coffee farm?
I think he owned it sounds better if I
say,
you know,
one day my manager,
he was at,
he had a big job.
He's a big man at the coffee farm and
they're kicking him out.
They're moving them to Mexico,
their export Jesus,
and he just got some stay some,
you know,
or where they allowed him to stay there
a couple more months to appeal his case.
But if I love Jesus Christ,
the guy did it.
He came,
he came over here,
he was 15 he's a part of America now.
He's 30 something years old or 40 years
old,
whatever the fuck he is.
He could have already
serve time for,
for murder.
Like he could have done a full sentence
already.
His time positively.
He's actually doing well.
He's doing what you want is being a
productive member of society is
employing other people.
He's making coffee,
which I'm not going to fucking grow
coffee.
I need someone to grow that God damn
That guy's doing a great job.
That's a fucking American.
It is.
Make a move.
It's crazy.
It's like make you move to where you,
you moved around a lot.
Where the fuck were you and your 15 I
was a in Connecticut.
Yeah.
You're in Connecticut and I'm in
Massachusetts.
We have to move.
Imagine thugs come knocking on our door
with combat boots on holding guns and
say,
listen Morgan,
you got to move.
You can't stay in California anymore.
It's too many people in California.
You've got to go back,
back to the east coast.
Insane.
So same thing that they're doing it.
It's insane.
It's,
it's,
I don't,
I mean,
I dunno,
I don't,
I don't get it,
but I went on where you were when we did
the,
uh,
the end of the world podcast.
You guys did that one.
I remember it coming out at the end.
Hammered,
hammered,
hammered.
As I say,
hammered since I had been hammered since
Florida results came in and everything
was already done.
And I show up and it's a,
you know,
a row on stage
and I get there and I have no,
I have only feelings.
I have no,
nothing in my brain is working to
connect pieces are really be,
you know,
remotely sort of eloquent.
I just came out and I was like,
eyes is bad for people and everyone's
going to be racist that we,
you know,
people should be able to do what they
want.
Like I just had a charity on and started
making out.
Did we?
You don't remember that I didn't make
out.
No,
just kidding.
Front of anybody,
but,
but uh,
but burb just hammered me.
I mean,
he came back with with,
you know,
basically I felt there was like a lot of
energy that I came in with the worst
thing that's ever happened.
Just happened.
That was my energy and I felt like there
was a lot of,
you know,
don't know,
it might not be that bad energy that
night,
but hey,
this is what's really going on.
First of all,
you got a bunch of comics in front of an
audience,
right?
That's the number one thing that's
happening.
This fucking election is to us,
to me and Bert and anybody else who's
there,
it's like this is an opportunity to talk
shit.
Okay.
And the fact that there's an election
when I'm like,
we're,
we'll deal with the consequences of
Donald Trump being president later,
but right now we're here to make people
laugh and have fun and burn is on fire.
It was on fire.
He,
he was a,
he shines and those things like no one.
Yeah,
he was just like one after the other
smashing it.
There's a video online you can get on
youtube that's like the best of Bill
Burr at the end of the world podcast.
Yeah,
he's just slaying.
It was,
and I came in like,
and I like threw a cup of gasoline on
the fire with my opinions.
I was like,
yeah,
but it's not really in a pan.
I mean it's like you have to understand
from the perspective of a Zine,
not saying you have to understand,
but the people listening,
right?
Like when would do something like that.
There's a bunch of comics and there's an
audience like we're not,
we're not always going to deal with
what's going on.
We're not going to be somber.
Surely be considering the fact that,
okay,
well now we don't have a president
anymore.
We've just elected a buffoon to the
biggest popularity contest in the world
is what we did.
It's a popular person one now and now
we're fucked and he's an egomaniac and
now he's in charge of the nukes.
Congratulate Hell you could fire the FBI
guy.
Look at that.
You just let a reality star just start
firing the people that you need for
critical intelligence,
people that have been involved,
the intelligence industry and the
intelligence community for decade after
decade after decade,
you let this reality star just start
firing people.
It's nuts,
but it was also the best place I could
have ended up that night.
Like I can't imagine having spent a,
I mean I,
I I think I went to bed at like she got
together with Jen Kirkman 7:00 AM your
time.
I looked at her twitter and I was like,
I just got to stay away.
You guys are freaking me the fuck out.
Like Jesus,
he,
this is a bad system.
It's been a bad system since people
figured out how to make phone calls.
You know,
as soon as people figured out how to
make phone calls,
you didn't have to get a guy on a
fucking horse that carries your vote and
your request for sovereignty and your
personal state by a messenger that us to
take it to some fucking representative
as take it to Congress on this fucking
boat.
Like you don't have to do that anymore.
So since we don't have to do this
anymore,
this idea of one person running the
whole Shebang through a representative
of each individual state,
it's archaic.
It's communication is too good.
Now the bottleneck is the system.
The system needs to be redesigned.
It needs to be redesigned.
It's not impossible.
No one's saying we shouldn't have
government.
I'm not an antigovernment purple,
purple,
purple person looks like I'm not an anti
military person or an anti police
person.
I just think it all has to be managed
and engineered the right way.
Like you can't have just complete
anarchy in this country,
but we have to have the will of the
people.
And right now it's definitely not the
will of the people.
This is just some weird system that
someone's figured out a way to win.
And then once they're in the system,
we're realizing all the flaws of the
system.
People are quitting and getting fine.
You're like,
well,
this is not the most efficient way to
run this thing.
Right?
But there's no,
uh,
there's no,
it within the system.
There is no,
here's how you change the system like
that has been established.
And then you have to do that in a way
that doesn't,
uh,
you know,
make everybody implode.
So the system,
the design of the system,
and this is a more than I've,
I've paid attention more to the
political system in the last two years
and I think I have in my entire life.
But there's all these checks and
balances that are in place to sort of
prevent someone who's an irreputable
person getting into a position of power
and then changing everything.
There's enough checks and balances to
keep that in place.
And that I think that's important.
And that's a beautiful thing.
And having all these representatives
that represent both conservative and
liberal attitudes kind of keep things in
balance to a certain extent,
but it's not the best way to do it.
No,
the best way to do it would be to get a
guy like Elon musk and say,
hey man,
the way you,
uh,
figured out how to put fucking tunnels
under the earth where the cars go on
sleds and that eliminates all the
traffic in La.
And the way they figured out how to make
like a solar box that sits in a garage
on the wall and it powers your whole
house from the roof and the way they
figured out how to make roof shingles
that are actually solar patent,
the rate of the figured out how to make
an electric car then go 350 miles.
How about tell us how to fund this
thing,
right?
Like you're definitely smarter than me.
Yeah,
I mean most people does he make the
decisions?
Is it like,
cause I just think about like when they
change rules and major league it,
I always find it like interesting like
that a group of people got together and
like now what is it?
Overtime football over time says shorten
now and they like,
like I,
oh now it's a timid as now it's five
minutes and we all just go,
okay,
like who's who's the board?
Who's the person who gets to say,
okay,
now this is the way that the government
works.
I mean that's it's ellen process.
Well,
football is very different obviously
because it's a game and you're trying to
make the game better and more exciting.
If they were just trying to fuck with
people and make politics more exciting,
maybe that would be more of that.
Maybe that would work.
I just make it,
how do make this better?
How do we make this better?
How do we make people like this more?
How do we make people feel like they're
involved?
How do we do this?
But again,
I usually like changing the rules.
It seems like the,
I just don't eat,
I don't know how long.
Something like that takes.
Is it,
is it over generations?
Is it tomorrow?
The rules are this.
I mean how do you do that?
I think you make people park at the
bottom of a hill and you put the voting
booth at the very top of the hill and
only the people that can actually like,
unless you're physically handicap,
then you get a pass.
Then we'll figure out another task for
you,
but only the people that figure out to
get their fucking lazy ass to the top of
that hill.
Those are the only ones who get to vote.
Hi,
fine by me.
But that's a big thing.
You're going to have to tell somebody
whether it was I hope and say,
all right,
I'll probably say,
mountain hikers are just going to run
the world.
Alex honnold is going to be our
president,
that rock climber dude,
he's going to be number one.
No,
I just think that if we just come up
with an alternative system that somebody
designs and we slowly implement it like
in stages,
you know,
but every time someone doesn't like
something,
everyone is so aggressively angry now
and everyone is kind of a,
you know,
on the,
on the precipice of snapping.
And I feel like any kind of suggested
change to a lot of people is,
is terrifying.
It is terrifying.
And it should be because if somebody
fucks it up and Putin's this whole
thing,
you know,
that could be a big goddamn disaster
too.
That's always possible.
Like this is his closest that's come.
I'm like,
this is as close as it's coming to
something where he's kind of 33%
approval rate or something like that
except the pole that he found.
So it's 50% yeah.
What does that hilarious that you can
put up a picture.
It says 50% of the people like me and
the,
you'd be like,
wow,
he's really doing a great job.
Like you're never going to see a
president with a hundred percent
approval rate.
It does not.
Okay.
It's so tragic that mean he is,
he is.
I can't think of a time my brain has
been this consumed by,
uh,
by a president.
Right?
Like,
you know,
positive or negative.
I mean,
I,
you know,
I liked Obama,
but I never thought about him as much as
I think about trump.
Even if you have like things like
vitamins,
vitamins would not have a 100% approval
rate.
Right.
There's people that will like flip
vitamins.
I don't even need them.
They saw and they would give it a,
well,
like actual western medicine doesn't
have a hundred percent approve of.
There are people who go like,
no,
I don't want any treatment for my
cancer.
I'm going to,
well that's because
there alternatives and there are there
is there some people that believe that
you can do more work like to cure or to
a halt cancer in its tracks by altering
your diet and proving your immune
system?
I believe that more than like a,
uh,
you know,
no,
the Lord will provide my medicine,
but I think more and more doctors are
acutely aware of the factor that
nutrition
plays down.
I think they changed,
they make changes to people not just
like give them drugs and give them,
you know,
anti cancer medication.
But there's doctors now more
increasingly more and more that want you
to hate.
You drink too much,
stopped drinking.
Are you smoking cigarettes?
We definitely got to get you to stop
smoking cigarettes.
We got to get you to eat healthy.
Like,
or here's what's important.
I feel like you're directly talking.
No right now.
Right.
Uh Huh.
I just think that uh,
you have to pay attention at doctors
too.
Like these motherfuckers might have
figured out a way to cure your cancer,
but you've got to listen.
You can't listen to the holistic healer
lady that has incense burning in her
fucking house.
She smells a bit Julie.
Maybe a little from column a.
You gotta be careful though.
Truly smell and motherfuckers,
I just did some weird,
uh,
I did,
Kalanick at some,
you know,
hippie ranch type place.
Dude,
you gotta pipe up your ass.
Had a pipe up my ass.
What was that like?
Uh,
it was uh,
it was oddly a oddly positive experience
and I didn't think it would be,
I know it was a guy I was in Bisbee,
uh,
around,
Doug's place and I,
you know,
took off for the day and got to
Kalanick.
Wow.
Have you done that before or was it on a
whim?
A semi on a witness?
It was like,
yeah.
Yeah.
I called the play loud,
was looking for healthy things to do in
the desert
and that was one of them.
What percentage of people take colonics
on a whim?
Like,
what percentage does it even 10 where
people would just walk down the street.
Look,
you know,
it'd be fun.
We should really,
yeah,
I don't think there's a lot of colonics
ways where like advertise for foot
traffic.
So,
uh,
yeah,
come on in and we'll stick a pipe up
your ass.
But I try,
you know,
it's that thing where I'm not like you,
I don't have a,
a,
I don't have a healthy lifestyle.
So I find myself hitting walls and then
reaching,
kind of grasping for,
um,
activities that seem healthy and
enjoyable,
which is why I've like,
you know,
like,
oh,
I'll go,
there's a boxing surfing,
I'll go play basketball,
you know,
but I don't do it as consistently as I
ought to.
That's why it's always impressive to see
you,
you know,
peak form,
constantly
do things.
You like doing it.
So I did.
That's how,
you know,
I like it.
I like sport.
I love sports.
That's a great way to stay healthy for
me.
I found out somewhere along the line
note fit for me to be better at certain
sports.
I have to do shit.
I don't want it to like lift weights,
run hills,
like stuff like that.
Like if you don't do those things you
don't have,
like if you want it,
you want to make an analogy to machines
like you ever weird opportunity with
your body where say if you're in a race,
you can turn your body into a sports
car.
Okay?
Like you can literally turn your body
into something that does something a
regular car can't do.
It can move faster,
could pick up more.
It can explode.
It can make corners better.
Like you can do that to your body.
You can give your body balance.
Like you take a yoga class two days a
week for four months.
Don't tell me your body is not better.
It's going to move better.
That's going to be more balanced.
You're going to,
you get to be able to change the
suspension on your car literally by
putting in the work.
But the [inaudible]
work and suck a fat one.
Sorry Dude.
I know it's so hard at anything,
but you got to get excited about doing
hard shit icon.
I get excited about,
uh,
I get excited about the prospect of
getting in better shape after the age I
am now than I was before.
Like I get excited about being that
person that I've seen happen.
I'm like,
Oh,
I've seen people do that.
Get in better shape after 35.
I guess I can do it,
but there has to be thrilling,
but I can't,
you know,
it's,
it's getting there.
You don't want it bad enough.
Rocky.
I now
I know,
I know.
There's no tomorrow.
It's my favorite quote.
Yeah.
You know what you have to do.
This is the big one for everybody.
For everybody listening,
write down shit you have to do.
But I do it.
I write down things I need to work on,
things I'm going to do.
Yeah.
Like I wrote down my schedule for the
week.
I wrote down like this week I'm going to
lift weights three days a week.
I'm going to run two days a week and I'm
gonna do yoga two days a week and
period.
Like there's no,
no negotiation.
So it has to do those things.
So that will,
I'll do that for the week and then I'll
make sure I make those checks off cause
there's a lot of times where I want to
fuck off,
but I know I have to make my schedule,
I have to get it in.
If I don't get it in,
then I fucked up.
Like I gave myself like a schedule and,
but then I get things done and it
doesn't seem any more stressful.
In fact,
it seems less stressful because I don't
have to like him and hall of whether I'm
going to do something.
Like I have it written down,
I have to do it and then I just go do
it.
Sounds,
uh,
I'll do that.
Then it's got to just write it down and
stick to the script.
Because as a comic,
one of the best things about us is that
we're impulsive and that we like to blow
things off shore and we like to question
the validity of certain actions.
Like,
why am I doing that?
Fuck that.
Oh,
how about I just jerk off and take a nap
or whatever you do.
You know?
I mean that's what we do.
Will people were impulsive.
And that's one of the reasons why you're
funny cause you come up with a thought
that maybe other people wouldn't
entertain.
Yeah.
I mean I,
I,
you know,
it's,
it's just a mat once I'm,
once I'm in,
once I have,
once I got some downhill motion,
um,
you know,
keep going.
Yeah.
That's the moment they,
yeah,
that's the initial start.
I used to go boxing like every day for
years.
A few years.
You know,
that was when you were in New York right
now is that heroes go to the wild card
like everyday for like,
oh that's right.
And then,
uh,
Morgan Murphy is a big fucking boxing
fan.
You,
you're not ever have conversations about
by,
you know,
a lot of shit.
I,
yeah,
I used to come and know more.
I mean I hit embarrassed with a,
it was sports stuff cause I'm such a
fan,
but I'm not a by any means a
statistician.
I'm not,
uh,
a good remember of even names.
I just obsessive Lee Watch sports isn't
that hours and hours,
hours a day.
But isn't that funny though?
Like if you're talking about like a
television show,
like a,
yeah,
I saw that show.
What,
wait a minute.
That's a good show.
You know,
who is,
who is the main character in lost?
What was his name again?
And what was the,
you know,
like there's no shame in that,
right?
But a basketball game for the same time.
Like who was in the finals?
Yeah,
I think of like fights I've been to,
and then I can't even think of,
I'm like,
I know who won the fight.
I don't,
I,
I don't even remember who they find
Kovalev Andre Ward this weekend.
I watched a little,
uh,
I listened to a lot about it,
but I missed it.
That's the other thing too,
is I've watched,
I stay home and watch so much shit.
I mean,
you know,
I love sports.
I find it to be the most soothing.
Like I,
I,
if I'm,
if I'm in a job,
you know,
writing something all day,
I look at my,
the sports schedule that night and I get
excited that,
oh,
I have a thing to do at eight.
You know,
after my work is done,
like I just,
I wrapped my days around it so I'm
trying to go out and do more shit as
opposed to being locked in a locked into
a schedule that uh,
determined by what slap boxing matches
on.
And I used to stay home to watch
everything and I didn't for that one.
Yeah,
I hear Ya.
Okay.
You get,
you know,
it comes in waves.
Right.
But I listened to the,
I mean I,
you know,
I've,
I have opinions about it having not seen
it,
which is
you still have opinions like uneducated
ones from whatnot just from watching
what I eat from seeing what I did see.
I feel like it was like,
I like I get mad about certain
stoppages.
Oh really?
Like what did you see?
The Kovalev Ward?
Yeah.
And I taught it was an early stoppage,
definitely narrowly stoppage.
I don't think he felt that this
shouldn't,
someone's on his way down.
Here's the question though.
Did he have a standing eight count rule?
Like I don't know if there's a standing
eight count rule in that fight.
I could see if there was find out if
there was,
cause I feel like that's what should
have happened if it happened.
But in some fights,
I believe they don't have to have a
standing eight count that correct me if
I'm wrong.
I don't think that's the case in all
fights.
And I think in some championship fights,
they don't have a standing eight count.
And I think that's a speculator or a
specification,
right?
They put,
yeah,
that,
I don't know.
I just seems like an obvious
stipulation.
Ah,
yeah.
I mean,
the last fight,
I'm trying to think of a Jamie,
you'll find out.
Jane Doe.
I made a,
I made,
uh,
I was in,
Arizona during the Canelo,
uh,
the Chavez fight and I made everybody
watch it and then that wasn't a good
one.
It was a bad one.
And it was the worst part about it was
that everyone knew I was the reason the
fight was on.
Oh No.
So everyone,
it was a,
it was like I couldn't,
every round I wanted to be exciting
because I wanted people to not get mad
at me for ruining their night,
but instead I was responsible for a
boring night.
And then I was like,
I enjoyed it.
Even though it was boring.
I just wanted to see who was going to
fight Golovkin and that was my,
that was my sort of,
you know,
my horse in the race was whoever was
going to win.
Right.
My favorite fighter.
But most people thought Canelo was gonna
win.
Handly but that was the problem was that
like,
Chavez didn't really want to put himself
out there,
risking a great [inaudible].
He's never been,
uh,
I don't think it's trainings ever been,
um,
as disciplined as some,
like Canelo is about that life.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean,
he's trying to be the best ever and just
trying to be the best.
It's hard to be.
I tend to mean her being a,
being a rich kid.
Boxer just feels like a born rich kid.
Well,
I mean,
Chavez Jr,
he's,
oh,
sorry,
my canal.
No,
no,
no.
I was just saying that,
uh,
you know,
just that just seems like a hard place
to come from.
Oh yeah.
And he's,
you know,
his dad is the fucking greatest of all
time.
Julio Cesar Chavez is arguably the
greatest Mexican fighter of all time.
I mean,
he's,
he's up there.
I saw it,
I saw Chavez Jr fight and um,
at the staples center and they brought
his dad out first and I was like,
I was like,
oh,
just the poor shadow you got to be and
that your dad gets honored before your
fights.
Rough.
But you know what,
there's this Guy Kron Gracie and his dad
is Hixon Gracie who's like the greatest
Jujitsu guy of all time.
And the sun is a world champion.
Yeah.
Fucking beast.
And he's one of the best guys on the
planet earth.
Like legitimately 100% self motivated,
not like,
you know,
it doesn't need to,
it's not like the same sort of Chavez
situation.
Right.
So it doesn't always happen that way,
but it seems like fighting in general,
younger for fighting tends to come from
a place of poverty.
I mean,
it tends to,
yeah,
but again,
it doesn't have to.
No,
no,
no.
But I mean,
even like even it and Mary,
like,
you know,
uh,
oh,
what was his name?
It's like rust belt dude.
Uh,
rustbelt nail.
Yeah,
the guy a this an American dude who,
uh,
I always forget when,
I can't remember his name.
He's from Molly Pavlik.
Was it Kelly?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Am I wrong when I shave?
I shaved head.
Yeah.
I had a moment.
Bad motherfucker.
He just ran into Bernard Hopkins.
Bernard Hopkins had them figured out.
Just tuned him up.
Yeah.
I like it.
Brought a blog article about that,
about that fight,
because it was just a masterful
performance by Hopkins Hopkins.
I was actually coming home from a UFC
fight overseas.
I was in Europe when I watched that
fight and I was like,
that motherfucker.
So good.
I kind of,
so smarty,
I've been watching,
but I've written for,
Oh,
you root for people.
I just like,
I don't know who,
who's who.
I feel I have,
I think wide just started even watching
hockey.
It's like I played so many sports as a
kid.
Like I can get into the sports I know
about,
but when I don't know anything about it,
it's like,
it's like we're going out to like do
anything else.
I'm uncomfortable getting into something
that I come from such a,
I have such a huge blind spot about.
Right.
I don't know.
I'm just like,
how am I going to learn everything?
Immediately I tried to get Ian Edwards
to school.
Me On soccer.
I didn't last a few weeks.
We've been talking about doing a soccer
companion.
He took me to a bar once and we're
sitting there watching some games,
like some big time soccer game.
It was pretty good.
It was fun.
It's fun being next to Ian because he
knows everything.
He knows as much about soccer's.
I know about mma.
He just rattling off who this guy is and
what this team is about and what their
scores,
and he has a soccer podcast too,
that he does.
I forget who does it.
What do you remember who he does it
with?
I love that dude.
I love him.
He's the best.
Such a nice guy.
He's the most underrated comic alive
today.
So funny.
I,
you know,
I quoted a joke of his and a in the
writer's room at two broke girls and my
boss was like,
his joke is that,
and I was like Ian Edwards and he hired
him.
Great move.
Yeah,
it was like,
it was a,
it was,
but it was just like,
oh yeah,
the end's got this joke and everyone was
fucking dying.
I selfishly don't want anybody to ever
hire him as a writer again.
I want them to just do standup.
I think that's what he's doing.
I mean,
I think he just was a little short Gig,
but yeah,
no,
he does them every now and then,
but I just feel like people don't know
how fucking good he is.
He's so good.
He's,
and he's such a good guy.
Yeah.
Just one of the best guys ever.
True.
What do you think about this conor
mcgregor?
Floyd mayweather fight.
I mean,
it's a spectacle.
I guess I'm excited.
Uh,
I'm excited about it,
but I feel like it's going to be another
big notch and I may,
whether spelt and I don't think he needs
another one.
Like I just,
I get a little bit,
ah,
I get it.
I,
I respectful.
I May,
whether it's a boxer,
but it's not the kind of boxing I get
excited about watching,
even though I know it's technically,
you know,
it's going amazing.
It's going to be a boxing match.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's going to be an actual 12 round
boxing match,
so we're going to get to see some sort
of an athletic competition.
Um,
but yeah,
sorry,
I just don't,
I don't see how mcgregor can
be better than the best boxers in the
world who have tried.
Yeah.
He won't be,
he won't be better than the best boxers
in the world,
but what he might do,
first of all,
he's definitely gonna make it exciting.
It's going to,
the trash talk is going to be fucking
as,
it's going to be epic.
It's going to be a fun Spec to go and he
has legitimate scary one punch power and
he's way bigger.
So it's all about whether or not he
could hit me.
Whether she has a at one 50 something.
I don't know.
That's a good question too.
How much weight does he have to lose?
How much is in and make them dehydrate
himself even give a fuck.
Does he ever even when respect is skills
enough to make them dehydrate himself
like he did with Canelo cause he made
Canelo cut a shitload of weight.
Sure.
I think he made a fight at one 50.
Is that correct?
File what?
Floyd mayweather made Canelo Alvarez
fight because Canelo Canelo's a big
fella.
I've seen him in person.
Him getting down into one fifty's a
rough,
rough suck.
I think that,
um,
it's always scary when you look at these
days and they just look amazing.
Macy ate it before the tariff.
Like Chavez,
I mean,
you know,
was a tall guy.
So he's one of the worst I ever saw was
when connor made it to one 45 we fought
Aldo.
It's like Jesus Christ.
Like he looks so gone and dried up at
the Wayans and then the next day it
looks like a go real
canelo came in at one 52 it says,
and this fight is at one 54 it is at one
54 that's what they're making it.
Interesting.
Okay,
well connor's not going to have a hard
time making the one 54 now this says
Canelo weighed in at one 68 no,
that was his last fight with Chavez jr
or Chavez Jr.
He fought above his weight class,
actually Chavez Jr I think it was
fighting once 75 wasn't he?
And he came down,
maybe they,
maybe it was a normal weight for Chavez
Jr just for the 30 day weigh.
And when he fought me with her,
oh it was 30 30 days out.
One 66.8 yeah.
Well they had stipulations in the
contract,
like how big he could be at certain
points,
you know,
sturdy.
They just wanted to dry them out.
What's the,
what's the whole a cargill?
I mean is it,
are they going to have all boxing?
Because it's a good question.
I think the only way to fight is going
to be interesting skill wise is if
connor figures out a way to a mall him,
he's almost got to like close the
distance quick,
get him up against the ropes and just
hit him with like shots while he's
holding them.
He's almost got to clip him in some sort
of weird awkward like my Donna like
exchange ever seen a fight with my
donald,
a floyd hat.
But Floyd got clipped by a big overhand
right.
I think it was at the end of one of the
rounds,
like very end of the round,
his legs dip like Whoa.
A little Jig,
a little,
a little wobbly and it's just because he
got mauled.
It wasn't because skill wise he was
commensurate and then when floyd came
back in the rematch,
he just boxed his face off.
Just fucked him up because he just
wanted to let them know like,
look dude,
I barely took you serious in that first
fight.
It got close.
But it only got close cause like the
sloppy bra and then you just put a skill
clinic on them.
And the second fight sacrifice wasn't
even close.
I think that that's the only con,
but that's not how connor normally fight
sound like a swarming face.
First brawler type dude.
He's a guy,
he's like cautious about getting hit and
I'm,
I'm thrilled about it but I'm also a,
I,
I wish,
I wish I,
I wish I knew more about your side of
the tracks.
Well we don't know enough about connor
because connor has never had a
professional boxing match.
You know,
and the thing is you see a striking,
but you only see striking when he's
working on kicks and wrestling and all
that other shit too.
Just kicked him.
Like would that,
I mean just,
it just didn't do it just to let them
know to do it would be fucked up.
He fucked up.
But it would be hilarious.
Well after you'd probably,
there's probably some stipulations in
the contract and say,
can't get them in an arm bar or choke
him.
Just kicking him in the head and knocked
him out.
Would be worth losing all the money and
then getting more money out.
Can you imagine?
He would be a god damn folk hero if they
got in close,
if they got any clothes and floyd was
like sucking and Juke on the outside and
he threw a jab to cover up our left high
kick and that left high kick.
Next I'm just,
and you see floyd go limp and he would
go limp.
He'd never been high kicked like that.
Jesus taught it'd be crazy cause if he
didn't know it was yeah
he could clip them with it.
Like if he had no idea.
If you hid a kick behind a punch like
fighter is a lot of fighters do to like
throw a punch,
literally a cover your face so the kick
is behind it already and then boom,
the kit comes like while your vision is
already,
you're thinking about the next punch and
bang the kick lands and you get chaos
happens all the time.
If he did that,
that would be insane.
What have you are worth it?
It would be with fuck everything up
because no one would ever trust another
fighter from mma to ever fight a boxer
in a boxing match again,
cause we've only had the up.
The opposite happened.
Really?
We could they after this,
could they do an MMA fight?
But the two of them,
no,
no.
Got It.
With last 30 seconds,
maximum relax.
If Connor wanted to give them an ear
beating for 28 minutes,
seconds.
Look,
connors so much better as a wrestler,
as a submission.
Artists as a kicker.
There's just no way he'll,
he'll hit him with spinning elbows and
shit.
Like there's things you can't do in a
boxing match that you're not expecting
and if someone's just kicks your legs
once,
you're going to be like,
oh my God,
what the fuck?
Now
I'm just trying to think of a way to
make money out of a,
out of what's going on.
I mean,
you know what's going to come at
hundreds and hundreds and millions of
dollars.
Yeah,
right.
I said only way.
This is the only way,
but this is a giant big difference
though.
Floyd would have to learn how to fight
MMA style.
Who would have to learn how the Stop
takedowns cause I have to learn how to
check leg kicks and you'd have to learn
how to defend submissions and that will
take years.
And he's not going to do that at 40
years old.
I don't know what he knows now as far as
wrestling defense and what he knows
about kickboxing or Jujitsu or anything
else.
I don't know what he knows,
but if he knows nothing,
he's 100% fucked 100% bet.
The House on it fucked.
Like connor might win a boxing match.
I mean maybe there's like a,
a small percentage chance that he just
runs in there and clips floyd with a big
shot and rock some and then takes him
out.
I don't know what that percentage is,
but if you ask a boxing expert,
there's like 4% 5% right.
That's what a boxing expert would say,
which I'm not.
But I'm an MMA expert,
and if they fought in an MMA fight,
it's 100% the connor would fuck him up
100% no ifs,
no ands,
no buts,
no chance,
no chance.
It's connor is going to be farther away
from me with him than anyone has ever
hit him.
And he's going to be kicking him in the
stomach,
in the legs,
and it'll soften him up in the rounds or
five minutes long.
And eventually he gets a clinch.
And when he gets a clinch may whether is
fucked,
he's going to the ground,
he's not going to be able to stop,
but he's going to get mounted.
He's gonna get elbows force fed into his
eye socket,
his nose,
his mouth,
his jaw,
the sides of his head,
his ears.
He's going to get elbowed in the ear.
He's going to get punches dropped down
on him when he's totally pinned down and
defenseless,
he's going to have a knee on one of his
biceps.
While those guys literally on top of him
pounding him in the face and he won't be
able to get up do,
you won't be able to stop the crucifix.
You won't be able to stop anything.
He'll be tied up and smashed on the
ground until he decides to choke him,
so he's big.
You'll be completely defenseless.
So in that sense,
the odds would be insane if mayweather
decided in the next two months because
the fight is going to take place in
August.
If he decided in the next two months,
which by the way,
I feel like as soon am I wrong,
I feel like it's too right.
It's very quick.
It's not.
Maybe it's on too soon.
Maybe they'd been negotiating for a long
time,
but at least connor knows something
about boxing or this could be a thing,
but if they just took it from now and
said,
tomorrow,
two months from now,
you're going to have an MMA fight.
Holy Shit.
The odds would be 100,000 to one like if
you ask like any real MMA expert,
they'd be like,
how fucked is he?
Oh,
he's 100% fucked,
hundred percent fucked.
And boxing experts think that mayweather
is 100% fucked,
but they'll give him a forced smile.
Slight chance.
You never know.
It's crazy people.
It's throwing punches.
You never know.
Cause may mayweather can throw a punch
for sure.
And Connor Control Punch for sure.
Right.
Who knows what happens.
Who knows?
Most likely though me whether outboxes
on,
but you could see con and landing
something could be crazy.
It's [inaudible].
He's just the hardest person to light.
It's not just that he's the greatest
guy.
He's a,
he's the hardest person to land a punch
against.
That's why it sounds it.
Yeah.
It just,
he's the best defensive boxer ever.
Yeah.
That's why it's morning.
It's not too,
I mean it is,
it is,
but I don't find it boring on a
technical level.
I find it boring unlike a social,
like I liked the social element around a
fight and the excitement and yeah,
it's very good way to put it.
It's,
it's not a good,
he's not like the best,
you know,
you can't look at your pizza while
you're eating it cause you've got to
keep your eye on the screen.
Like it's like a Tyson fight.
Yeah.
Tyson was the best example of in a lot
of ways what was wrong with people
liking boxing?
Cause I just want to see someone get
slaughtered.
Sure.
You know,
and then Arturo Gotti and micky ward is
like the other side of it.
It's like neither guy can slaughter the
other guy and they keep slaughtering
each other and coming back like that's,
that to me is always been my favorite
kind of fight in torn personally because
I know how dangerous it is for them
cause it's such a horrible,
horrible experience for their body.
Just exchanging punch after punch after
punch.
A guy named Tim Hague,
just died this past weekend and he was a
former UFC fighter who,
uh,
lost in the UFC and then went over and
was fighting a bunch of other
organizations and he sustained a series
of pretty brutal knockouts,
like boxing thing that wasn't at a
boxing acts like a he,
so he fought a bunch of mma fights,
had gotten knocked out many times and
then went in just two months after a
lot.
Well,
a big knockout that he just had an April
fought a boxing match.
So he had been knocked out in April,
I believe it was April.
I'm sorry if I'm wrong.
Um,
that's what I read.
And then he's fighting again in this
boxing match and he's outmatch it takes
his fight on short notice against her
really good boxer.
I think he has like a one and three
boxing record someplace that's not a
good boxing record.
And this guy just fucked him up and bad
and the Kao was brutal.
He apparently got knocked down several
times in the first round and uh,
and he got hit with some big bombs and
dropped in his head,
bounced off the ground and he died.
And it,
it is a very rare thing for someone to
die in boxing in the heavyweight
division.
It's usually the guys who dehydrate
themselves and then come into a fight
like really light.
Those are the ones that usually die.
So this is pretty rare.
There was like a serious beating in a
fight between um,
that really bad ass Cuban guy,
a southpaw,
uh,
big,
something.
Louise see if you could fit.
He's a top contender right now,
boxing in the heavyweight division,
but he beat up this Russian cat and
fucked him up and the guy wound up being
in the hospital for quite a long time
and his,
I believe his career's over at some
swelling and bleeding,
bleeding on the brain,
but he survived.
But Tim is a unfortunately passed away.
Scary Shit,
you know,
so those fights they'd come with,
this is a great consequence that we
don't feel as spectators,
although I think people feel it now more
than ever.
For sure.
Football too.
I mean,
I,
that's,
I can't,
I can't get over like when you hear it,
like just a crack of a helmet.
There it is.
Um,
why was it brain damage fighter allowed
to leave Madison Square Garden on his
own?
Yeah.
What is a homeboy's name there?
Ma?
Magomed Abdu Salam off Maga Abdu Salam
off.
And uh,
he was fighting a Mike Perez.
Okay.
Think that's the fight.
So I got the guy wrong too.
That's not the big,
uh,
Cuban heavyweight.
I think I fucked it up.
It's a different Cuban heavyweight,
by the way.
Have you been to the theater at the
garden there?
See,
it's a great place to watch.
Oh yeah.
It's amazing.
I love it.
The theater is amazing.
Yeah,
I'm doing stand up there.
Hello.
So I'm excited.
I'm excited.
There's a big UFC fight at Madison
Square Garden.
What does that guy,
Louis?
No,
Louis Gomez,
comedian.
There's a,
there's a,
uh,
top Cuban heavyweight and something.
Goddammit.
You want a name overlap and boxing too.
This guy was in a coma after this loss.
Yeah.
It seems like it was saying,
I think I got the wrong guy though.
Like that was the right fight,
but I'm trying to figure out who the
other guy is that I thought was this
guy.
Yeah.
I said another guy,
God dammit,
he's one of the top guys are really big
do's.
Ortiz.
Yes.
Louis Ortiz.
Thank you.
I thought I was going crazy.
Um,
I never remember anything.
That's why the people I've talked to
people where they're like,
yeah,
you should do a sports thing.
And I'm like,
I'm not,
again,
like I reiterate,
I'm a fan.
I'm a,
uh,
such a fan,
but I just don't have the,
uh,
the knowledge to pull out of my little
knowledge.
Satchel,
if you did,
would you be in doing alternative boxing
commentary?
Like say,
say if like,
I feel like this is going to be the
future of interactive television.
You're not going to have just one
commentator till you have the,
you want.
Yeah.
You have to be the one who would be like
a,
this is fine.
Everybody.
Oh,
this,
you know it.
Uh,
I,
it'd be the one who'd be like that.
I like,
I think he's cuter,
but I think the other guy is better.
So look,
how about this?
How about maybe a guy sitting down with
his girlfriend and she's like,
I don't want to watch this fight unless
we watched Morgan's commentary and the
guy's like,
deal,
deal.
We got it perfect.
I get to watch the fight.
You get to listen to Morgan.
Like that'd be,
that's a fucking good idea.
And that's not a hard setup.
Now I talked a lot about the cut man.
I love it.
I love a cut man.
I love a closeup of a,
of a,
of a wound over the eye of an end swell.
Oh,
softening down.
It's fascinating.
There's tissue,
there's something soothing about it.
Now when you were boxing where you're
sparring there like a couple times a
little bit with like a friend,
like not,
but let's just tap each other or just
really as I go with my friend amy and we
would,
we would,
you know,
we would work out.
It was my workout.
I used it as like a workout.
And then I became buddies with,
uh,
with Freddie Roach.
And that was like at a time,
it was,
I was working at Kimmel at the time and
um,
and uh,
this is,
uh,
12 years ago or something like that.
Nah.
And I would just work out and then
occasionally do a little,
like Freddy would have to a little
sparring,
but it was very,
you know,
very,
a couple couple of points here and then
done.
Like,
I was very,
I was nervous.
I spy when I was a kid.
I did a lot of karate as I sparred as a
kid.
I kicked some kid in the head,
like a testing and I remember the,
uh,
instructor,
saying,
good job to me.
Whoa.
I just nailed some kid in the head.
But,
uh,
the,
no,
I mean I went to,
the coolest thing about the loud card
was I feel like I,
uh,
Pacquiao was,
was training there every day pretty
much.
And Freddy would let me stay when they
closed the gym for Pacquiao.
He let me stay and like watch him train,
which was,
that was awesome.
Like 12 years ago to do that.
Did you ever see Brian Callen at the
gym?
Ah,
yeah.
Uh,
I feel like I feel if we took,
if I didn't see him there,
we talked about it,
definitely count boxes at a time.
He spars,
he's always talking to me about a
sparring and wait,
two stops barring your brain is already
soft.
Like what are you doing?
I get excited about,
I,
I fought a,
um,
uh,
it was,
it was more of a bit,
but uh,
for vice magazine when it was just the
magazine we did,
uh,
I fought a heavyweight,
a female heavyweight.
We did it in a prom dresses.
Um,
a very,
she wasn't allowed to.
Really?
Yeah.
She like could get her belts taken away.
And stuff.
But I brought this dude from the,
uh,
from the wildcard is like my,
my corner man and we both wore a prom
dresses.
So she was a real fighter,
real fighter,
heavyweight fighter.
And then at one point I think I just
jumped on her back.
Oh Jesus.
And tried to like knock her down.
So she didn't try to hit she,
you know,
the plan was for her to try and I was,
my plan was for me to allow her to try
and then her a manager was like,
Nah,
she's not allowed to.
It's like you legally,
she wasn't allowed to hurt me.
I know,
but I thought it'd be,
you know,
good to see you get knocked out.
Yeah,
that'd be my fun little,
you know,
he was at,
don't you want like I get embarrassed
when I haven't done something that
sounds like I would like to be able to
say I got knocked out once.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Don't say that someone would come and
knock you out.
It's not good for you.
Here you are.
Oh,
there's me.
She's picking you up.
Yeah.
Well she seems friendly.
Heavyweight.
So how come you stop doing it?
Oh,
can we stop boxing?
Good technique there.
Look how you're a thank you.
Shut off the back foot.
A Freddie Roach used to call my right,
the cannon and a real honor to now that
you and Brian you get together narrate
your own life.
Um,
I don't is the Canon?
Yeah,
I think I like,
honestly,
I got like a little,
I got like depressed and stopped boxing
and started going to this coffee place
and stuff.
Like it just,
it's,
that's,
that shit's boring.
I got look up the depressed stop going
to the gym.
So the gym didn't help you with
depression?
Like no one was like a big dip.
So there's a few months away from that
kind of stuff and I just stopped going
and then I didn't go back because it was
so by that time I,
I wanted to,
but it was also that Jim became,
it was like,
it's like Jeremy Pins there everyday.
It just became such a scene that it
became not what I had started going
there for,
if that makes sense.
It does.
You know,
and I,
and I love it and I should absolutely go
back and,
and,
and frankly,
I think Freddie Roach been as nice to me
as he has been in my life.
Is one of the stranger,
you know,
kind of.
Oh,
I don't know.
He had no reason to sort of take me at
any did.
I almost moved in next door to the
wildcard with Frat.
Like it was like,
you know,
he's a dear friend for a long time.
When I got to go back to them,
we were going to live,
I was going to live next to the gym
almost for a second and the apartment
attached to the gym.
But um,
I was just in the middle of that would
be a crush shit at bells going off to
me.
Me,
me,
me.
Yeah.
But he's great.
He took me to like boxing writers,
awards,
dinners and stuff.
I got to meet a lot of like great pete.
Me.
It was,
it was,
it was a cool time of my life,
but I just sort of,
you know,
and then I moved to New York and I think
that was a big part of it too is did you
find out if Coleville of ward,
if they had a standing eight count,
I found someone trying to describe it
analysis and facts and said that it was
a unified rules.
No standing account was in that.
Oh well if a guy quits and there's no
standing eight count,
you've got to think of it as a knockout.
It's like mma.
But if there's a standing eight count
that would have given it to them there
or what he should've done is probably
take a knee Kovalev probably should have
taken a knee and if you took a knee then
he would get a 10 count that that'll be
considered
a knockdown low blows.
Big Low blows.
Yeah,
he definitely,
yeah,
you definitely got hit low.
And then there was a couple of them that
are questionable like on the beltline
apparently they were saying Kovalev was
belt was pretty high.
It's,
it's,
it's funny cause there tends to somehow
unboxing something happens be it,
uh,
you know,
horrific judgment,
which I think happens a lot.
Like to allow there to be another fight.
Like it just seems to be like something
always fucking hell.
That's why when I have a lot of people
over to watch boxing and like I hate,
I hate the parts of the sport that
seemed like it's fixed because I can
appreciate the fight as a whole.
Even without an outcome I think is
fixed.
No,
no,
not this,
but I just seen inboxing.
There always seems to be something
something happens that would make a
rematch more attractive.
Right.
But that's just the nature of
competition on a big scale like that
with crazy consequences like the um,
the Klitschko Anthony Joshua fight.
Like that's the consequences of f I just
fucking chaos.
Just guys getting knocked down,
get back up and knocking the other guy
down or holy shit.
Then a kind of a controversial ending.
They stop it.
Oh,
it looked like he was defending himself.
What do you think there's more
controversial endings and boxing than
there are in a mma?
I think people make split second
decisions on the referees in the heat of
the moment and when you're going to have
that,
you're going to have mistakes.
It happens all the time and it's,
it has nothing to do with like there's a
lot of,
a lot of mistakes.
I do not think it's fixed.
Not by any stretch of the imagination.
I think especially like with respected
fighters,
I think people do have biases for
certain styles and there's certain,
there's certain referees that we'll let
a fire defend himself further than some
will.
Some will,
especially in mma,
you know,
judges are,
he's sitting in a similar,
we're not,
but I always,
I always find it hard to explain to
friends who come over who never watched
that stuff.
And I'm like,
I love having people over and having
like it.
Like I said,
the social aspect of like sports to me
is really fun.
But when friends come over and they
constantly see results that they don't
understand,
they're done with the sport,
you know?
Whereas if you like it more or you can
be like,
ah,
it's a,
is that it happens.
Problem is you're a people pleaser and
trying to get these people to like
something that you like.
Yeah.
You should just let them go.
Let them think it's fixed.
I'm not so many conversations with guys
like mmas fixed man,
just admitted for that.
Oh I don't want to talk to you.
[inaudible] this is a silly way of
approaching this issue.
You don't know anything.
Yeah.
And you're trying to pretend like,
you know something so that we're right
from the beginning.
We're fucked like this.
We can't have this conversation.
You're pretending that you've seen
enough eyes,
you understand fighting enough.
You've competed in a,
if you've been hit enough,
you've seen people get hit.
You know enough to know when something
that's real and something's not,
you know,
everybody else can't figure it out.
But you figured out that a lot of the
fights are fixed.
There's some fixed fights.
That's why like,
I mean,
I,
I right.
I mean obviously like last five years
I've been obsessed with the Golovkin
cause yeah.
He's just a knockout artist and you
can't,
you know,
that's not it.
There's proof to it.
I mean,
maybe with MMA too,
it's like you can,
I would say that early stoppages and
boxing and probably more,
no,
they're very common.
Or are they calling in both sports?
It's just people making mistakes.
But my point is there are going to be
fixed fights.
[inaudible] just going to be people that
do things just like there's referees and
NBA apparently they get busted trying to
stretch games out and trying to call
fouls on certain teams and they work for
people that bet money and they try to
shave points.
That shit's always gonna exist.
There's always going to be someone who
tries to talk to a referee and says,
listen buddy,
it's,
I'm not saying that you should fix the
fight.
I'm saying if you see somebody get hurt,
stop that motherfucker.
Stop that fight,
pull that trigger a little quick and I
was going to be mad at you.
And there's that,
you know,
there's definitely that.
But how often does it happen?
I bet it happens.
Pretty rarely.
I bet it's much more people making
mistakes,
much more people in the heat of the
moment.
Much more just the nature of the chaos
of combat sport competition.
Just wacky shit happens and people make
big mistakes as referees.
Just like,
you know,
people like you and I make big mistakes
talking on a podcast.
You just talking off the top of your
head,
right?
Sure.
Make mistakes then.
But with a referee,
you're making a mistake like this other
guy's career.
Like for Kovalev to not recognize the
low blows,
to stop the fight,
like the way he did Kovalev fucked up.
You should have taken a neat,
yeah.
Yeah.
I mean,
but that's the thing is that I,
a lot of these,
a lot of these things can lead to
another fight like that.
So saying it says that without the
controversy there's less attraction.
Yeah,
no one's going to agree to it.
Look,
Andre Ward is not going to agree to some
sort of a predetermined outcome is not
going to agree to a predetermined
outcome.
So those two principles,
the most important parts of this
equation would never fucking ever agree
to.
Let the other person,
when there's not a chance in hell
Kovalev is just going down from
[inaudible].
Oh No,
I don't.
I don't know.
I just think that,
no,
I don't think it's fixed.
I just think the controversy itself
makes a rematch more attractive to our
shores.
But the idea that somehow because it's
finished,
I don't,
yeah,
yeah.
But a lot of people do.
Yeah.
Dude.
Boxing that guy at the party.
Everybody.
Everybody at my house,
like ever.
I also seem to invite people over for
the wrong fights.
You know what I mean?
Where you're like,
oh,
the last one was fucking great,
and then you've,
and then you have people over and it's
like,
eh.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's always how it is.
There's so many people that just,
they just don't,
they've never competed and so like they
just,
and there's also people that want to
call bullshit.
They want to be the first person to call
bullshit.
So they like,
they're a little itchy on the trigger
calling bullshit on things.
He's always given me that.
Right?
Contrarians,
lot of contrarians,
none of them.
A lot of smart people are contrary.
Some of my smartest friends,
just disappointing.
Sometimes some of my smartest friends
were always wrong.
Well,
it's like what led them to be smart and
curious.
It's like this distrust of things,
but contrarians also fun,
right?
You see the tide going one way,
like fuck that Thai sparring,
sparring,
verbal sparring,
keep it flowing a little.
Uh,
yeah,
that's a big,
same with comics,
right?
I always,
I find that the,
uh,
the guys I tend to be attracted to a or
a attracted to our,
uh,
our,
our contrarians are just,
are just,
it's,
it's a fight from,
you know,
from the get go.
Really.
That's what you like a little bit.
He's like a little bit for a little bit
of a verbal sparring.
Yeah.
Let's see if they can hang.
And I,
you know,
I,
it's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm my,
uh,
I'm,
I'm totally driven entirely by being
like s,
you know,
mentally stimulated.
So it's just then,
then I'm,
then I'm in like sexually,
but if it's not fun,
the Banter's not fun,
then I'm,
then I would have no interest in fucking
someone.
I hear you.
That's not how I feel at all.
That's a,
that's a difference between guys and
girls.
It is very much session comics.
I've heard that many times like girl
comics,
or they would never date a girl that
wasn't funny.
And you never hear that from a dude.
No,
no.
That's,
that is,
uh,
it's,
it's funny that's,
it's one of the things I talk about the
most with a lot of my female comedian
friends,
but it's just,
there's not,
there's no part of me that would be
sexually interested in somebody who
wasn't a,
if not funny.
I mean,
if not funny,
they'd have to be brutally a smart on,
uh,
you know,
on a level that I don't even understand
what night Stephen hawkings shit.
Yeah.
Like I'd have to just,
Eh,
I don't,
I don't know.
I like to,
this is,
this is going to sound wrong,
but,
uh,
there's something fun and attractive
about,
you know,
uh,
intellectually being put in your place.
Wow.
That's weird.
Like you would like to be intellectually
choked.
Yeah.
A little bit.
I don't,
I,
you know,
I don't,
uh,
I,
I don't know,
maybe it's not the popular opinion,
but because a fuck,
it's your opinion.
It doesn't have to be popular if you
enjoy it.
It's also like if somebody is,
it doesn't have to be my thing.
Even if someone's great at their thing.
Right.
And I have no understanding of it,
I find that to be a track like it.
So it doesn't necessarily always have to
be a comedian and someone who is,
you know,
brilliantly hilarious.
Like I've been attracted to guys who are
just brilliant at a thing that I have
zero comprehension I how you even get
good at it,
let along graded it and something fun
about it.
Yeah.
I'm always fascinated by those people
for sure.
But I don't find them attractive.
No.
Like a fur.
I will believe me.
There are things I wish I wish I was
more attracted to.
Like I wish I could just,
I wish I was attracted to,
to,
to money and looks and all the things
that,
you know.
Yeah.
I wish I really though this is the same
on original.
Um,
it seems like there'd be more options
and then it would be easier as opposed
to waiting three years to find someone
who just like hits the right button and
you're like,
oh God.
Amen.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Be like tuned into someone in a mental
way.
Like your minds are tuned into each
other where you can speak on the same
terms where you can,
you can both recognize the humor in
things.
You both have opinions on things you,
you both enhance the conversations that
you have.
Like you throw in something that makes
me laugh and I throw in something makes
you laugh and then boom.
It's always so much more fun.
It just is.
It's just,
that's how it is with friends.
That's how it is with everybody.
That'd be,
that's like what I said about bar,
like having that podcasts with bear like
me just wouldn't mean burr alone and
we're talking shit or text messages we
have back and forth to each other.
They're hilarious.
It's like that.
Like to have a friend like that as a
cherished thing,
like to have someone that you could sit
and then if you could fuck them to oh
shit.
Yeah,
that'd be fun.
All right.
Very rarely happens.
Christina Palicki in Thompson Jura is
one of the rare ones were one of the
rare too,
too funny comedians that get together
and they both have a great time
together.
Bonnie Mcfarlane and rich vos and other
one.
Those are two running the contenders for
the throne.
Those are the two contenders for the
throne though.
As far as like funny is married Kabul a
hundred percent I don't see anybody else
that's like at that level,
Bonnie and rich and Tom and Christina.
I don't see anybody else at that level.
I'm trying to think.
It's rare,
but they're outliers.
Think about it and it Francella Gero Oh,
that's how she,
I'm sorry.
Stop.
Moshe and I fucked up Natasha.
Sorry.
There's,
they're both hilarious.
You're right.
I fucked up.
That's number three.
How do I not remember them?
If that's dust number three,
those those three people other than that
who I don't know.
I got,
I mean that's three out of 300 million
there.
One out of 100 million.
Most of this smart funny guys I know
don't need that in a,
in a woman and,
and that's,
you know,
it's not my place to judge.
Like I wish there's part of me that
like,
I was like Ah,
you know,
how could you date her?
She's a fucking idiot or whatever it is.
It's not my job to judge who,
who uh,
stimulates you.
But you know it's,
it's,
it would be easier if I had more options
I think.
Do you think it would be cheesy if
motion Tasha went on t and went on stage
with tee shirts that say one out of 100
million
cause that maybe that could be like
their tour name cause they really are
like if they're a really legitimately
hilarious couple,
they're both hilarious.
That's maybe one out of 100 million is
that,
that's pretty legit,
right?
I mean,
I'm trying to,
maybe there's somebody else and I forgot
you comedians when I was like 21 and I
was like,
oh,
they're crazy too.
Can't have this kind of crazy people
feeding off each other.
That just doesn't seem like a wise move.
Oh.
And also it's too complicated.
I've seen what happens when guys data
comic and then they break up with each
other and then she comes around with
some new dude and the guys all bombed
out and like that happened with Ari and
Natasha.
Oh yeah,
I know.
Yeah,
it's disastrous.
I was like,
Hey,
yeah,
don't do that.
No,
no.
Just be friends.
Unless,
unless you gotta do what you gotta do,
you know it could work at,
the problem is,
is that you're in the same scene to
someone.
See,
you got to work through all of your shit
around the person that hurt you and
that's,
you know,
that's the hardest.
But you might come out of it.
A better person might come out of it.
More Open minded,
more easy going more forgiving.
Just deal.
Just overcome positive.
I try to be,
I tried to be marketing.
I do my best.
I don't always succeed,
but I do my best.
But again,
it'll,
you know,
it'll work out.
It's all gonna work out except for this
fucking yellow stone.
Think God dammit or done.
So a lot of earthquakes.
Do you know,
I'd like a guy who does that,
like measures earthquakes.
Seismologists but like,
no,
it was more about like,
uh,
like a,
a real cynical seismology who's like,
we're done.
Because what if you really liked guy?
But then you found out he was into jazz.
Um,
it's happened.
It's happened over.
Be Like,
oh no.
And you come home to your apartment De
de,
De,
de.
[inaudible].
Every time he called me,
there was jazz on in the background.
Every time.
No,
but he was a,
you know,
very serious actor
wanted,
he just wanted it on in the background
and put it on in the background.
Right before you called.
So I called someone,
someone's calling me,
let me see more sophisticated.
Brian callen used to leave books out on
his table that he wasn't really reading.
I called him out on it.
I came over to his house one time and he
had the catcher in the rye or something
like that,
sitting right on his coffee table.
I'm like,
bitch,
you are not reading that.
He started laughing.
He goes,
I'm not like,
what the fuck do you have that here for
man?
He goes to impress girls like,
well,
I knew it.
It just,
it's so obvious to impress girls who
don't ask any questions.
Yeah,
thank you.
Know like he'd ever have to defend it or
get into it or it go at,
what's your opinion of it?
Why would you say to grow?
Ask questions.
That's just Jesus Christ.
It seems like a disaster waiting to
happen.
If you date a girl and right away they
come with the questions.
So what books have you read recently and
like,
oh,
Jesus was not going to work.
Aye.
Morgan Murphy.
Yeah,
we just hit a wall.
Stop talking.
What do we do now?
It's just kind of rebuild momentum.
Talk about it.
And I wish I was like a,
you know,
a big exciting lady.
You know?
That's
a lot of,
with a lot of movement.
I think one of the best things you've
ever done is that Carlos see a thing
where he did his material.
Yeah.
You said that you did it in 1920 would
you say 19
like 1912 I've tried to make it obvious
that I was fucking with people,
but it's not every like a,
you know,
every few months I check,
I see what's going on over there and
every comment is like,
oh,
I don't care.
He does a better like it was fucking
with you.
Yeah.
You dummy.
It says 1912 what the fuck?
It's pretty obvious to the way you're
doing it that it's a parody that was
reading off a cue card.
I made him five minutes.
I think there are certain people that
are doomed.
They're just doomed.
You're never going to get to him.
You know?
It's like there's certain,
there's certain fish that can breathe
with their gills and they also can
breathe air.
They can suck air.
Yeah.
Not everybody has that ability.
Not Everybody has the ability to
recognize humor or satire or just to see
it in certain people that are there.
I just think they have a dull battery
for our brain.
It's uh,
it's,
and it's,
it's more a obvious
pronounced,
um,
you know,
now more than ever because of,
uh,
you know,
everyone's got a little bit of a little
bit of a voice,
Julia old computer,
well more of a voice we get to now we
get to see not only how they make their
own jokes,
but how they respond to yours and every,
the combination of both is startling.
Frightening that.
And also like these people are
illuminated now where they might've been
just in the shadows before,
some weird neighborhoods.
And the good thing about it is it people
that live in those weird neighborhoods
like kids,
they get exposed to way more shit.
Like there is such a difference between
when you travel and you go on the road
now and you go to a town like in the
middle of nowhere versus going to a town
in the middle of nowhere in the 90s.
You go to town in the middle of nowhere
in the 90s you were in an outlier post
like you were in like some mad max type
situation.
You're doing some Minnesota Gig in the
middle of nowhere.
Like these people aren't going to know
shit about the real world.
I mean they're going to be trapped out
here.
The town's only got 5,000 people in or
something.
You're doing like your college.
Yeah.
Good luck.
But now they might as well be living in
San Francisco.
Yeah,
they all have the internet.
Yeah.
People just know things now.
They talk now they,
it's funny,
Doug,
uh,
he and I,
and he's right,
like,
but he'll,
he'll shit on me a little bit about
like,
we'll go somewhere and I'll go like,
oh,
it was funny.
He goes,
that's not the road.
Like he has her real,
you know,
I'd be like a guys who let me like you
do like who have really fucking done,
put in the road,
work across the country,
across the fucking world.
Like I am admittedly not that person.
And the places that I think are sort of
a,
you know,
uh,
out there in middle of nowhere,
like he'll put me in my place so fast.
I'm like,
this is nothing.
What's the darkest place you been lucky
in terms of like exposure to
the light of enlightenment?
Um,
one day I did with Henry Phillips once,
uh,
was in my,
in my twenties,
a Chris Fairbanks,
Henry Phillips and I went like,
I,
I don't have any crazy.
So like I don't do,
uh,
I don't do the drugs that would lead to
better stories and the ones I have,
but I,
you know,
just like where you're just sleeping on
a twin bed with another comedian in a
kid's room because his parents on the
pizza place that you drove up to perform
at and there was like a 14 year old
vomiting drunk outside the went like
all,
it just that kind of shit where you're
just,
and you're a grownup technically you're
in the 20s and just going,
what am I,
what am I here for,
for $50 and a six hour car ride and free
pizza and the kids twin bed.
And like,
people are having a contest to see who
can piss the highest outside.
Like just that kind of shit where I'm
just,
you know,
I and I,
and at one point I sort of hate it now I
just,
you know,
I think,
I think the friends that I have who go
out and occasionally,
you know,
take me out to go with them.
Like I have so much fun now doing stuff
that I used to,
you know,
that they got tired of I think in my 20.
So it's interesting.
It's like a,
um,
a little bit reading,
big aerated while you realize that those
things can be fun once you become a real
professional.
First of all,
in the beginning,
you're so looking forward to working at
the comedy store or the Improv or
headlining senior name on the low,
oh,
the billboard look.
But once you've done that,
then you realize like there's actually
fun and these places,
the problem is me freaking out about
this two hours I have to spend in this
shithole bar.
I should be enjoying the fuck out of it.
I should be coming in here with a
relaxed attitude,
having a good time and experiencing this
for what it is instead of experience
like,
Oh my God,
I'm so frustrated because I really want
to climb my way as being a professional
comedian,
but I'm stuck in this shit bar.
But then once you kinda are,
then you realize like,
no,
no.
Those are actually fun.
Oh yeah.
Now I have my only thing with the,
with my book and guys like I just say
I'll go anywhere that I haven't been to
yet,
you know,
I mean name the place.
If I like it,
I'll go and if I haven't been there I'll
go.
Like I love the unknown of it.
But uh,
but I'm definitely not a a,
you know,
a veteran of the road,
which is a real issue is non direct
flights.
Oh yeah.
Any place where you go those number
direct flooded and you might get,
yeah,
yeah.
You could get fucked.
I mean for this,
this tour that Doug's doing,
it's,
he's his tour managers driving car out
from Arizona.
So the east coast mostly they're just
driving around.
And then I'll meet him out there,
punches and of dates out there.
That's a good way to do it.
Yeah,
I know.
Um,
my manager brought up getting a bus,
like doing a bus tour.
My,
hey,
doesn't ron white have a bus?
Uh Oh yeah.
He's got a number of one time.
Yes.
Yeah,
but that's wrong.
You know,
I have young kids like I'm not doing
that bus.
It's a bus when he has his kids out on
the road for him
also.
Um,
I like doing too much other shit.
Yeah.
I don't like being,
like,
if I'm just on the road for a month,
that's not a healthy mind.
Yeah.
I'm not into that.
I don't want any weird fucking momentum
taking over my life.
Well,
that's,
I feel that way pr like I can't do it
alone.
I don't want to,
I don't know if I have no interest in
doing it alone and frankly like I can't,
yeah.
I can't
afford to headline and bring people with
me.
I'm not,
I'm not that kind of a draw.
So I would much rather go out with
friends who can bring me do a little
less time and have a good time with a
bunch of friends.
Yeah.
Like that's fucking,
no,
it's not the,
uh,
you know,
front lines,
brave way to go about standup comedy,
but it's just like,
I've,
I've no,
no interest in,
uh,
in suffering
no road.
And why should you,
why do you have to have that interest
like,
well,
no,
I mean,
I think that there are certain people
who are like,
well,
you're,
you know,
you're taking the easy way out.
You're not headlining this week.
You're going out,
you're doing a,
you know,
a nice,
uh,
30,
35 Max.
And it's like,
yeah,
well that's what I'm doing this week.
So what,
who gives a fuck?
Why is that a bad thing?
I know a lot of guys do that.
They do that all the time.
They'll headline,
sometimes they'd go on the road and the
middle.
Yeah.
Because it,
shit,
the things that people worry about pick
apart just like,
so goddamn pointless.
Plus you can get the opportunity to go
out with standup.
Like why would,
why would you not want to do that?
And I figured out a long time ago,
like the,
the road,
there's two types of roads this road by
yourself,
but you can get real loan.
It's depressing.
It can get very lonely or there's a road
with friends.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's fucking great.
I remember looking at a window at like
Springfield,
Illinois.
I was like 19 or 20.
And I just,
I just looked out the parking lot window
and I was like,
this time,
this is,
I love stand up and I love comedy,
but I said,
this is not
for me.
This,
this will destroy me.
I did all of my gigs on the road by
myself until I could afford to not do it
anymore.
And then,
um,
right around the end of the nineties,
I started taking Chris Mcguire on the
road with me a lot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's a long time.
Once I could afford,
and it costs money.
Like you'd have to pay for the flight
and pay for the hotel room.
But I'm like,
I would rather be out a few hundred
bucks here and there and have a good
time.
It made the in the experience infinitely
better.
I went to do Phoenix recently just for a
night and uh,
to get like some,
some time in that I couldn't get an La
and uh,
so I went out there for the night to do
a long set and uh,
I said,
I'm bringing my friend and I realize I
either who you're trying to get,
her name's Chris and uh,
they were like,
oh,
you know,
she's,
we're,
where's she performed whenever I go.
She's my best friend from college.
He's really funny and she does some
standup and I was like,
I'm bringing her with me.
Like I like,
I was like,
fuck it.
Like it wasn't,
and she's more of a comedic actress who
does some live performance stuff and she
did fucking grade.
She had to do 10,
15 minutes.
She was,
she was
perfect.
I'm like,
I could have brought someone who's been
doing comedy 12 years.
I was like,
I,
I wanted to go with my best friend.
Right.
That's what I wanted to do.
I want to have fun.
Fun.
Yeah.
It makes it way better.
You're in Minnesota,
but your home,
yeah.
You know,
you're in Cleveland,
but your home,
it's the best.
It's the best.
And the camaraderie between comedians.
It's like such an unusual camaraderie.
It's very unusual.
Well,
it's,
it's also,
uh,
I got,
I remember being on the,
um,
the,
uh,
the track,
like we were,
you know,
Doug's a cranky traveler and a,
I mean he'll tell you firsthand.
And we were,
uh,
we,
we landed lax and it was like,
it just take a different airlines.
We had to get on like a shuttle to go
somewhere like a shuttle after the plane
is like,
you know,
when someone doesn't like surprises like
that sits on the shuttle.
But it's just like constant,
like jokes about like,
like we're going to Auschwitz but like
loud Auschwitz jokes on like the,
you know,
American Airlines shuttle with like
people around you.
I'm a little more sensitive to like,
I'll look around and go like,
oh,
we're not like tier,
but there's,
it's,
there's,
there's nothing better than being around
other people who like speak your
language and you don't have to explain
anything ever.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's one of the things that Doug said
to me once.
It was hilarious.
He goes,
he goes,
I think I could quit comedy,
but I could never quit comedians.
Oh,
that's like a sensitive shit is deep.
I was telling him like,
if everything goes wrong,
he could clearly organize some sort of a
village in Bisbee and all the comics
moved to him.
I,
uh,
I'm,
I'm considering,
I got,
I gotta have a,
I have a,
a busy realtor.
Yeah,
I do.
Thinking about buying not gonna.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not,
I have to,
I have to be in la.
My,
my work is in La.
Doesn't have to be in ally,
but I,
I haven't found a place that offers me
the way that place does.
everything.
I don't realize I miss when I'm in La,
like what are the second I get there?
It's,
it's a sense of calm.
It's a sense of reprioritizing your day
around.
Um,
things that have nothing to do with show
business and you know,
being around people who aren't in the
business.
I mean,
most of my friends weirdly,
are not comedians like that I hang out
with everyday,
but I don't know.
I mean the other day,
like I was there and we had a little
like pickup basketball game plan for
like 9:00 AM and like eight people
showed up to watch me play this dude
Kenny.
It's just small town kind of shit.
But with people who seem to have figured
out why they're there too.
And um,
I just really dig it.
I dig the whole vibe.
I dig,
I dig the city,
the town or whatever.
I liked the drive there even.
And I think it's a drive from La and now
it's,
I haven't driven from La and flying to
Tucson,
um,
drive like an hour and a half.
But I always was obsessed with like
getting a place and like Costa Rica and
Nicaragua or like anytime I go to
another country and I'm like,
oh,
this is it.
This is my spot.
Really.
And there's a lot.
Yeah.
You travel a lot when you were a kid.
I think so.
I think there's a part of me that is a
little bit of a problem staying still
because I had never knew a,
you know,
that kind of consistency.
But the thing I realized about Bisbee,
which,
which again is so like Doug's thing that
it's almost funny,
but it's,
Aye.
Aye,
It's all those feelings that I had in
even in other countries where it was
like,
it's getting away,
but it's close enough.
You know?
It's just,
but you still feel like you're on the
outskirts and you feel like you go back
in time a little bit there,
you know?
And there's something refreshing about
waking up and going,
I'm going to go get my coffee at the one
coffee place.
I'm going to go get my,
this kind of food at the one place has
this kind of food,
you know,
I'm going to go get my fresh eggs from
the lady who has fresh eggs and come
from her chicken.
Like it's just shit that I don't do here
and I didn't even think I wanted to do
until I got there.
I get it.
I like those places.
I Love Boulder,
which is much bigger than Bisbee but
still for the same reasons.
I think,
um,
what we do specifically also like you're
in front of crowds all the time.
I think there's like a real benefit to
being away from crowds and just smaller
groups.
People,
it's more relaxed
and it's also,
you know,
I think you go somewhere at a certain
number of times you meet kind of the
people that are there.
I mean obviously I've met a lot of
Doug's friends and stuff and
you know,
once you're not bothered,
you go from a place of like,
ah,
I wonder if anyone's going to know.
I know it annoys you think you're like,
I really like it here.
Then you're like,
oh,
I really love it here.
Then you're like,
I think I could have a place here.
So you're thinking about legitimately
picking up shop and moving to Bisbee and
then keeping an apartment here and then
when you're not working like in
Hollywood shit,
you live in Brisbane and you go on the
road from there.
Yeah,
not quite,
but I'm Ben.
I am thinking about having something
consistent that like I will probably
have to be here the majority of the time
for the foreseeable future,
but I'm curious about what it'd be like
to have my own little spot that I could
go to when I want to and I,
you know,
in,
in doing it and if not,
I realize I can go for a weekend and it
feels like a good it,
you decompress.
Fuck Ya.
You know there's a cave for sale.
Yeah,
I know he's trying to get,
did he see his trying to get so far,
I feel like,
I don't know if you are interested in,
but I know me Kreischer,
Roseanne,
norm and Doug,
like the people who have expressed
interest in this cave of going in and
getting it,
I was like,
oh,
I would live in that fucking insane
asylum in a heartbeat.
Dope.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's super dope.
You should get it thought about it a
couple of times from,
to be honest with you.
He should.
Yeah.
I mean I'm looking at like a,
you know,
a little craftsman.
One,
two bedroom.
I want just a little place to go with my
dog and stuff,
but you know,
if you get the cave,
I'll stay there and clean it for you at
the cave or knows where you live.
That's true.
Yeah.
Get a skid.
It get to keep outside.
Oh,
that's it.
That's what I need to keep outside.
And some wild havoline has roaming
around your yard.
You could hire a number of people there
who would gladly stand in the front of
your driveway with a gun.
Yeah.
Sweet.
How many guns they have.
Backup guns.
I don't know.
Living in a cave would be the shit.
If you could live in a cave.
It's carved.
None of the mountain there is.
It feels right for you and he's got it.
What I'm saying?
I'm saying that so far and Doug thought
10 people dug me.
Keep clicking.
Roseanne.
Bert,
you have to live with Bert.
I don't know.
I don't have to live with them.
I'm going to buy it to come stay over,
but you drink too much.
She can't live with you bro.
Look at this thing.
This thing's the shit.
Yeah,
you see the wall.
I mean all the outdoor stuff to the
right.
Some awesome stuff in this house.
I was thinking that I write my best.
That's what I,
that's what I keep thinking.
I keep trying to find the house that I
think I'll write and don't jump up
though.
You hit your head and die.
No one will find you.
Look at that.
That's the bed.
The bed is carved into the ground now.
That's like a,
that's like,
is that a fireplace in that?
Oh that's beautiful.
Got like a carpet and some pillows and
then you send a fireplace,
a yoga room.
Oh,
pretentious.
You have a room to do your yoga.
That's a little built in audio type
thing.
That's a real house.
Yeah.
And then a real house secure all this
land and water and shit.
So the real ass you take uh,
some Rambo type character again.
That's where I would work there.
Back it up,
backed it up.
Let's see where Morgan will work.
I work at that table.
Dude.
Would you have coffee and your wife be
pouring you the coffee?
Like a hunters Thompson,
that classic picture of him at Big Sur
and I need a wife.
You already have one tired a shit.
That lady who's trying to get you to
have a kid now.
My housekeeper generations.
She's your life partner.
She really is fucking amazing view.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I might have to buy their cave.
Keep going.
It's like if we were going to move to a
new spot,
this would be a spot to move to get in.
I would get in bikini shape for that
little lagoon plus to give me six months
before you,
before you buy it,
you could get resident tags
for animals and animals and the
mountains around there.
Don't shoot my dog.
No,
not your dive dogs to God.
It's don't accidentally.
I know,
but I feel like you're also got a
trigger finger,
itchy trigger finger thing.
So what you have to give the wrong
impression of me.
Thank you.
Think of more volatile than I am.
Um,
how many people live in Bisbee?
I don't know.
What is it?
Thousands,
five days.
10 hour at 5,000.
I don't know.
I have no fucking idea.
The elevation is really high.
That playing basketball was hard.
Like what's the elevation?
It's like a mile high.
It's crazy.
It's like,
yeah,
it's,
it's a,
I was,
uh,
I was deep,
deep.
I would say two baskets in 5,000 filers
lean in.
I was leaning over real hard.
I could barely play.
City was wow.
Population is 5,002 elevations.
5,000 populations.
5,005 five on both.
It's perfect.
Yeah.
I got a little,
this last time I was there,
I got a two bedroom,
airbnb,
little house hot tub.
While it should 85 bucks a night.
Two bedroom house.
That's a good deal.
What else?
Is there a gym there?
Uh,
you know what you got to ask Doug
because uh,
his buddy who says it just hesitant.
He just joined a gym that's like a
minute away.
Like that's right there.
Then they talk about that in Tucson.
He says an hour and a half drive,
hour and a half drive.
It's not that bad and really do
something.
It's like going to Santa Barbara.
That's what I said to like,
uh,
like everyone I work with,
I was like,
I'm going to leave.
I can be back in three hour.
Basically.
I just said let me know if I need to
come back for any kind of emergency shit
and I'll be back.
But wow.
Easy to go in the mountains.
Just get cold there at all.
Uh,
I think you get gets cold at night
sometimes,
but you got to say it's,
the weather's amazing in that,
like I've talked to,
I taught,
my dad called me was like,
I hear it's real hot there and I'm like,
it's so breezy constantly in Brisbane.
It feels,
it gets,
it gets really hot,
but not as hot as it does in other areas
because the elevation,
yeah.
5,500 feet is fucking high,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
Interesting.
You gotta do I slow Cape's economy?
They're like,
what do people do?
Nothing.
All the why they're there.
I don't know.
I just pile that.
Oh,
I don't know why anybody else is there.
I mean,
I know why I go,
how many people have moved there because
of Doug?
I think a hundred.
I think more than people would think.
Yeah.
It seems like,
it seems like there's quite a few folks
who hundreds?
No,
I don't think so.
I,
I that I don't think so.
I mean it's,
it's almost,
uh,
like I remember talking to Doug about
liking it and I almost felt like I had
to ask him like,
Hey,
I think I'm going to come out.
Like,
like,
is that okay?
I know it's your fucking town.
Like it's,
it's,
you want to be the one who finds it.
I mean,
I've been at like four,
nine brought my friend and I bought my,
my buddy bill from just a good friend of
mine out here.
Like W we hit the road like it's,
I would,
it's a kind of place that I want to
bring people to and show them to doug.
Get excited when you thought about
moving there.
I think,
uh,
you know what?
I can't tell it's you,
you can't tell that seems happy.
But then also there is a part of,
when a place is somebody thing you don't
want to intrude intrude.
Right.
I do that.
So I don't know.
I mean,
I also don't think I'll let you know.
I would just love a little,
a little second little rustic place
where I do nothing.
Do I do all my nothing.
I'll watch it.
I'll live in your cave.
Would you want to watch the game?
I'll watch the cave.
Would you?
Yeah.
No weird stuff though right now.
Whenever you let a comic wall watch your
house and then like are,
I mean I might have some processed sugar
in the cave if that's like I going to be
a big problem for you is going to be an
issue.
Yeah.
It's super bad for you Morgan.
Keep it out of your body and keep it out
of my cave.
I just take a picture of like Doritos in
front
of your favorite places in a cave.
Hmm.
It's funny.
If they can't get anybody to buy that
cave,
I would feel like that would be
something that people be trying to buy
up.
The problem is try selling it,
trying to sell a cave to someone who
could afford a $3 million cave like
this.
Not a lot of those dudes out there or
women.
This cave houses in France.
Oh.
Oh,
you're balling.
You're balling so strong.
You're on the side of a mountain.
Hope it doesn't go all pump.
Pay On your ass though.
But you know what?
You could do a lot of this shit with the
cave and Bisbee you could do a lot of
that low seating.
I see it happening.
I'm worth now.
I really want you to get that fucking
okay.
How would an amphitheater outside
amphitheater folk singers come by?
There's a small little amphitheater in
um,
in the park at busy.
Been busy.
Yeah,
a little one.
You could do a show there.
This a different one.
Oh,
I just typed in the cave house in
Bisbee,
but a lot of like cave houses are just
coming up to him.
I saw.
Yeah,
I saw a special on one of them
television shows about houses where
they're just,
just all cave houses.
People build houses in caves,
carving art into the wall.
Oh,
we're going back back to the caves.
Well,
just people are bored.
They just want something interesting.
Look at this fucking place.
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] where are he lives?
So God damn important.
Every place has a different feel to it.
That's why the idea of countries is so
fucked up,
stopping people from living somewhere.
Awesome.
Okay.
Well.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
it is,
it's,
if you told me like,
I can't go to busy anymore,
I can't go to her,
you know,
like I perfect example
pissed.
Somebody drew a line around busy.
No,
this is Biz Banya now you can't come in
unless you have papers.
What are you,
do you have any exceptional talents?
And we would want to let you into
Brisbane Ia.
Alright.
I mean,
Shit,
just 300 years ago,
it wasn't even real,
right?
300 years ago there was no American.
It's not too hard to believe that one
day Biz Banya could be a real thing.
Maybe doug takes over,
maybe they invent some stem cells.
They'll let doug live for a long time,
like way longer than he's supposed to.
I'm like five more years.
500,
500 years and 300 years from now,
doug is like some crazy old wizard mayor
is this is all the people in his,
oh,
those guys,
those guys have moved there.
Well that's Andy.
I know Andy Andrews,
Andy,
uh,
far green underwear,
black hat.
And then there's,
um,
I don't know.
So the dude's probably Biz Banians.
They'd need to a Biz Banya need to
declared their own country.
It's not a bad move.
Right.
This is going to stop you.
No one's ever going to lie there.
We'll leave you alone.
Just keep it low key.
It's cool.
You're five minutes from Mexico too.
You do a little drive and in Mexico,
shit goes down
south of the border.
Ooh.
Take the money and run.
All right,
Morgan,
I think we've taken too much of your
time.
It's almost 2:00 PM done almost three
hours.
What?
Yeah,
that's crazy.
God,
I can't wait to look at the comments.
Don't read that Shit.
Are you going to read that and know
that's why I read.
I don't read any.
That's why you get depressed.
No,
I don't.
I don't read comments for you.
I don't either.
I don't need someone telling me I sound
fat.
Oh,
where can people see you working?
They get in touch with you.
Work in the,
I am on twitter.
Morgan underscore murphy.
I'll be out on the road with the Stan
hope from the 22nd to the 3rd of July.
You can look at his website for those
days
and,
Oh yeah.
Doug's got a special thing coming out on
like a CSO,
I guess,
uh,
that,
me and Brendan Walsh,
uh,
it's uh,
Glen Wall.
He hosted this thing and a south by
southwest that's coming out.
Oh,
beautiful.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Doug's,
Doug's the executive producer hug like
hosted and brought out me brandon and
uh,
and uh,
Glenn.
Oh,
that's excellent.
And that's when,
when is that coming on?
Morna Murphy.
I'm glad we're friends.
You're very,
very funny.
For a year.
The best.
That sounded real.
Jamie.
Anything to say before we leave?
No.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you Morgan.
Thank you.
Bye everybody.
See you soon.